Welcome back, Master.
Ojoisama.
Um, actually, I took like a couple bites of my food... breakfast.
And I'm...
That's what I'm like, just kind of been sitting here like...
For those who don't know, I got food poisoning.
Um, and you're probably like, yeah, you probably...
It was probably something really delicious and worth it, wasn't it?
Probably was something that like, you...
You know...
It sucks you got food poisoning, but in the moment, it was like the best thing you ever had, huh?
Meep!
Thank you for the 20 gift cards!
Thank you!
Um...
So after, I went to Anisama for two days.
The first day and the second day.
I did not go the third day.
Not because I didn't...
But I just didn't have a ticket.
I never bought a ticket.
Um...
But...
After...
After Anisama day two...
Maybe Korya takes a look after!
Which if you don't know what Anisama is...
It's a big...
Anisong...
Event.
In...
It's like a three day event.
And it's really awesome.
They get like...
Oh my gosh.
I...
You know, I loved day two.
But day one was like incredible for me.
And um...
Uh...
I went because of an idol group.
I tried to eat Matara before she ate you, huh?
Uh...
That would probably just...
You know, that would probably actually kill me again.
Probably.
But...
Um...
Anisama day two...
I didn't tweet about it or anything.
Because...
Um...
I got home late and then I was like so tired.
And then I...
Went to sleep and then I...
Was up the whole night.
Throwing up.
And...
Um...
Laying on my floor in the hotel room crying.
But...
I...
Um...
Uh...
Day two was still so amazing.
Oh my gosh.
They opened with Aya Hirano.
Which if you don't know, she's the voice of Suzumiya Haruhi.
So...
Um...
She did three songs.
And one of them was Lost My Music.
And I was just like...
Oh my gosh.
This is so nostalgic.
And then...
The last song...
She was just like...
She was like...
Okay.
I'm gonna sing this last song.
And...
Oh my gosh.
They came out with the guitar.
And I was like...
Yes!
Yeah!
I was like...
Oh my god!
It's gonna be...
God knows!
And it was...
Oh my gosh.
I was like...
It was the most...
It was...
It was one of the highlights of my...
Of that day.
Because...
Even though it was like...
Basically...
The first person up.
Oh my gosh.
The whole room...
I say room.
The whole...
Like stadium.
Just lit orange.
Because everybody broke UO's.
It was like...
One of the brightest songs.
The whole night.
Because everybody was just so...
Excited.
It was like...
Oh my god!
It was so awesome!
And...
Um...
Oh my gosh!
It was so great.
Um...
And uh...
And um...
Sorry.
I'm gonna talk a little bit.
Just to make sure my stomach...
Settles down a little bit.
Um...
But I also went for day two...
To see my seiyuu Oshi Ogura Yui.
And she was...
She was so cute!
Oh my god!
It was my first time ever seeing her.
And I was like...
Oh, she's such an angel.
She was the cutest ever!
Ooh!
She was so cute!
Oh my gosh!
I was...
Screaming my head off.
I'm surprised I have a voice right now.
Um...
But day one was...
So much of a highlight.
Because...
Um...
Uh...
My favorite idol group, Denpokumi Inc.
Was there!
And...
Um...
One of the songs...
They had an intermission.
Because the event is actually quite long.
It's from like...
4pm...
To...
9ish...
About.
Like 9.30...
Depending.
And uh...
Um...
Before...
Before the intermission...
Um...
The singer...
For...
We are...
One Piece?
Was singing...
We are...
And all the acts came out...
And so I got to see my favorite idol group...
Singing we are...
Together...
And I was just like...
This is like the best...
Moment...
Of my...
Life...
Maybe...
My...
Living life...
My afterlife...
My whole...
My whole lives...
But um...
Oh!
And then day two...
Um...
One of my favorite anime song singers...
Suzuki Konomi...
And...
It was there too...
And um...
She...
Oh my gosh...
The way they introduced her...
Was so great...
Because...
Um...
She...
It was...
We were waiting for the next artist to start...
And then you just hear...
And I was like...
Because that's the sound from ReZero...
And she does a bunch of songs from ReZero...
So I was just like...
I was so excited...
And...
I was like...
Um...
And I was thinking...
I was just like...
One of my favorite songs from ReZero...
One of my favorite songs by her...
Is actually a song...
From an anime...
Um...
Oh gosh...
Like...
Motenai...
The...
The like...
Um...
It's not my fault...
I'm not popular...
Anime or whatever...
And um...
And uh...
Did you see?
Pricka Day is doing another ReZero collab...
I know!
Yeah!
Watamote!
Yes!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh...
Sorry...
My brain...
I'm just waking up a little bit...
Um...
Yes!
Watamote!
And I was like...
You know...
To see her perform that ever...
Would be like...
You know...
Kind of a pipe dream...
I was just like...
But I was thinking it...
Like...
When she...
When I...
Like...
When she came on...
I was just like...
It would be so awesome to hear either that...
Or to hear...
Um...
Redo?
Since I did a cover of Redo...
So I was just like...
Wah!
Either would be so great...
And actually...
She did a collab with Serizawa Yu...
Which is another Seiyuu that I really really love...
Um...
She's also part of IRIS...
Another idol group...
An any song idol group...
Basically...
And I was like...
Oh my gosh...
Serizawa Yu and Konomin singing together?
Oh my god...
I'm gonna...
I'm just gonna throw up here...
I'm just gonna...
Go to heaven here...
What's happening?
You did a cover of Redo?
Yeah!
I didn't...
Private it...
It's still on my channel...
And um...
Uh...
They actually...
Did a cover...
Of one of...
Um...
Uh...
Serizawa Yu's songs...
Debiru...
And I was like...
Kawaii...
And then afterwards...
They were just like...
Cause...
Konomin is just like...
I'm always so...
You know...
Cool...
I have this cool image...
I wanna be cute...
And so they did...
They did that song...
And then...
She was just like...
Oh...
What's this reaction?
Maybe...
Maybe I'm not very cute at all...
Maybe I'm not very cute...
And then...
They also...
Then afterwards...
They led in with that...
So they were just like...
It's...
It's not my fault...
I'm not cute...
And so...
Then they led in to...
Doing the...
Watamote opening...
And I was just like...
I was...
Screaming...
I was going crazy...
I was like...
It was so great...
I just love any song...
Like...
Trisail was there...
Um...
Oh my gosh...
Uh...
Sorry...
Um...
So much...
So many people...
Were there...
And I'm just like...
Wow...
It was so...
It was such a...
It was such a great time...
So...
Yeah...
I did that...
And then yesterday...
Oh my gosh...
You guys...
I had a dream come true yesterday actually...
But I can't talk about it yet...
But even though I had food poisoning...
I pushed myself because I was like...
This is the most important...
Day of my afterlife maybe...
So...
Um...
Ahahaha...
But that should...
Uh...
Be out soon-ish...
I got bad news about my postcards...
I found them ripped...
In two...
In the recycle bin...
I taped them back together...
Oh my gosh...
I'm so sorry...
Wait...
What?
Did like someone rip them up?
I'm so sorry...
No...
I'm sorry...
But yeah, sorry, my brain is a little foggy, because I haven't gotten much sleep, because, you know, the night before I was up all night, I didn't sleep even a little bit, because I was so sick, and last night I was just like, I didn't sleep at all the night before,
I'm going to get so much sleep.
And I ended up going to sleep around, like, midnight, and then still, my body wakes me up at 6am.
I'm like, why?
Why did you do this to me?
I have some... oh, my food poisoning, that's right.
After Anisama, it was very late when I got back, because it's in Saitama, it's a little far.
And so, not a lot of places were open.
There was actually a noodle place that's kind of close to my hotel.
That I was like, I'm going to go eat there, because I'm pretty sure it's 24 hours.
And I get there, and it was not 24 hours.
In fact, I was standing outside the door being like, oh, my gosh, this place is supposed to be 24 hours.
And a staff worker saw me, and then, like, came outside the door and shooed me away.
He was like, we're not open.
And I was like, no!
And so, instead I was like, okay, well, you know what?
The only thing that's...
The only thing that's close to my hotel is McDonald's.
McDonald's!
And I was like, oh, they have a teriyaki cheesy burger or something, something.
Something.
That's what did me in.
So, now I'm here with Un-Metal.
And some morning spaghetti.
Hopefully the spaghetti.
I thought maybe something like a pasta would be easy on my tum tum.
Maybe.
It's got lettuce in it.
Robbed by the hamburglar.
When you want ramen but get McDonald's...
I know I was so in the mood too.
I was so in the mood for ramen.
Forgive me Minto for I have sinned.
I might own a certain spicy doggy.
What does that mean?
Sorry, I'm choking on my spit.
Went to my first maid cafe at Idol Fest to repent.
Said Japan was fun.
I'm glad you had fun!
Minto's not McLovin' it.
No.
In fact, I was kind of excited too.
Because I was like, oh they had that advertisement recently.
Like the Japanese McDonald's had a recent advertisement that was like...
Using Marisa Stoll the precious thing.
So I was like, you know what?
Maybe Touhou will save me.
But it did not.
Anyway.
Let's play UnMetal.
I'm not sure how far I will get in today.
If I beat it, if I have a crazy hair and I beat it, awesome.
If not, we'll just go a couple hours.
The super chat is from iDaggit.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Sent bravely default.
Sorry for delay.
Thank you!
I'm pretty sure I got it.
Thank you, thank you.
You are a soup.
I wish I had soup right now.
Nine years ago, their private army was decimated by a secret organization.
These men escaped to a new base off the coast of Africa.
Today they survived as soldiers of fortune.
If you have a problem...
If you can find them...
Maybe you can hire...
The D-Dogs.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
It's been nine years since Metal Gear Solid V.
Isn't that so crazy?
And then everybody was just like, you can only post this today.
Of the doctor being like, it's been nine years.
Oh my gosh.
That's my phone.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
The alarm is going off.
It's like, wake up.
Oh.
Oh, my tummy.
Oh, it hurts to move.
I'm afraid it's been nine years.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep.
Shut off alarm.
Wait, what is this?
Oh my god.
Someone just texted this to me.
And I saw this earlier.
You guys, I saw this earlier and I like jumped out of bed.
Apparently, Edgeworth is going to be a skin in Among Us.
Like, Edgeworth from Ace Attorney is going to be a skin in Among Us.
What is going on?
I've had several people message it to me.
And I'm like, look!
Ace Attorney in Among Us!
And I was like, why only Edgeworth?
But it makes sense because of the...
because of the...
the...
the remake.
Thank you!
Ahem.
The collection coming up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shame it's not Godot.
Makes sense, I mean.
Okay.
Let's load game.
I'm gonna have to remember how to play this, so give me a moment.
Give me a moment.
A moment.
So this is Punch.
Um, this is Roll.
Which I never use.
I got like a comment on the Vi last time that was just like, She didn't even roll one time!
She doesn't even know there's a roll button!
And I was like, AH!
Sorry, I just kicked my mic.
Um...
Actually, I did roll.
Like maybe five times.
Okay?
I rolled maybe like five times.
What's going on?
Hold on.
Um, shoot.
Uh, W is the codex.
So let's talk to Colonel.
Copy.
I managed to leave the building.
Now, you have to get as far away as you can.
I'm on it.
Damn.
This jungle is dense.
You're a suit.
Thank you!
Hope you feel better soon, mate.
Thank you so much for the cookie.
What about, um, this is Robert, right?
Jesse here.
Do you copy?
I hear ya.
Oh, okay.
Um, shoot.
What else was there?
Space is to like, fire the gun.
How do I get into my inventory?
Um...
My area.
How do I get into my inventory?
F?
Oh, F.
Okay, perfect.
Okay.
Um...
And then...
C was to use stuff, I think.
Look, I'm rolling.
How do I get what's in the truck?
Ooh!
Die, truck!
I forgot the potty.
Yeah, we have a used one.
And then we have an unused potty.
Okay, it's gonna take... Oh, there's three guys down there.
Okay, let's try this way.
In my escape, I ran into a gang of hounds that were sound asleep.
Ahhh!
Oh my god!
Smell...
Ears...
Uh...
Hear...
Still ears...
Their sense of hearing was 100 times stronger than ours.
I had to pass between them very slowly in order to keep them asleep.
The further I could tiptoe around them, the better.
To advance slowly, press and release the direction key repeatedly.
Don't keep it pressed.
Wait...
Like that?
Like this?
Don't keep it...
Like...
Like that?
Tap, tap, tap, tap...
Tap, tap, tap...
Thank
you, thank you!
Chu!
Good luck on your adventures!
And notice the video title is Unmetal.
Sounds like something to rival Metal Gear.
Tap,
tap, tap, tap...
Tap, tap, tap, tap...
Ah!
Oh my god, that guy's trying to escape.
Oh shoot, okay.
Oh!
Mike, aren't we supposed to shoot him?
No need.
Let's make a bet, Mike.
How high?
How high what?
Fuck!
The landmines!
Oh!
The look on your face!
Mike, you're a dick.
Yeah, I know.
Oh my god!
It was like, how high his body's gonna fly?
Could I have saved him, you think?
Oh!
Oh, no!
I think... oh, uh, see, see, see, see.
Okay, we're fine, everybody.
We only... okay, how do I loot them again?
X?
Yeah, okay, okay.
We're fine!
I remember how to play the game.
So, this way is the landmines.
Oh.
Oh, that's not very funny.
Why'd you hit Mike first?
It's just... what happened?
We'll put him by the tree.
What is this?
Why is this a question mark area?
I feel asleep.
Hey!
It's... I'm sleepy.
Oh, thanks.
I'm sleepy.
Jon, I'm sleepy.
Oh my gosh.
Yippee!
I feel asleep.
They even put this in the game.
They even put that in the game.
Why is everything question marks though?
Oh my gosh.
I love that reference.
Wee!
Oh!
I splattered all over.
Not that funny, Teehee.
I said that.
I said it wasn't very funny.
So sad.
He's all splattered.
I don't remember how to use the gun.
Never mind.
I remember how to use the gun.
What is this place?
Why is it so spooky?
Oh!
Okay.
Um...
I wonder if...
Does it...
How do I wear it?
Oh shoot.
How do I wear this?
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
How do I wear it?
I can't remember how to put it on.
See?
Oh, see, see, see.
There we go.
Viewers are reacting to a player named Mike killing the streamer in a game of Among Us.
Okay.
Never mind.
That didn't do anything.
Interesting.
Okay.
Well, this is a mysterious place.
Uh...
It sounds scary.
It sounds like a horror room.
We shall be back.
Use chaff.
Okay, let's go to the other side.
Okay,
let's go to the other side.
Can I go down, you think?
Is there a landmine or landmines?
Hmm...
Um...
You guys, I...
Well...
I accidentally touched the doll.
This is fine, actually, because...
Now I didn't lose any health to those spooky... to that gun thing.
So you know what?
This actually works.
That was actually the ideal situation.
I think.
This part is going to be annoying to get back through.
My depth perception, you guys.
My depth perception.
There's three guys here.
Dog, dog.
Don't send dog, dog.
Can I punch this?
Hmm...
What would be...
the best way...
to do this?
Hmm...
A
chloroform?
A chloroform?
Do I have that?
Oh, I have to, like, soak the...
Wait...
The chloro...
Oh, wait!
I have it!
This, right?
If I use this...
Will they go to sleep?
I'm sleepy.
I have to be fast, though.
Hmm...
I think I should take one guy out...
before the other guy looks...
and then shoot the other guy.
I feel asleep.
How's the audio, by the way?
Let me know if too quiet...
or too loud, or whatever.
Never mind.
I didn't have to shoot him at all.
Yippee!
It's good?
Okay, cool.
Oh!
Wait.
I thought this was...
stamina.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Heh, heh, heh.
What's down here?
The gate was locked.
I had to look for another exit.
Oh.
Well, what was the point of me coming down here, then?
I'm gonna put him inside the truck.
All guys go in truck.
All truck.
Come here.
Alright.
Okay.
All truck.
Nice.
Easy, easy, easy.
So we have to go back through the dogs again.
We do have the god mode.
We can use...
Bill Cipher.
I feel like a...
Goofy.
I...
I don't know.
What if it was just one leg?
What if it was one mine?
What if it was just one?
I wish I could save.
Oh, wait.
I can use my potty.
But we don't know when the next bathroom is.
Uh...
How high, chat?
No!
Heh, heh, heh.
Don't say it like that!
What if I beat up the machine that's controlling...
the...
That's controlling...
Whatever the...
The turret.
Okay, fine.
Oh, ru...
Shoot the turret.
Maybe?
I thought about that too, I'll be honest.
Let's try it.
Okay.
Maybe I can dodge and shoot.
This is...
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah!
I'm scared in here, you guys!
Wait, this is scary!
Come on.
Ouch!
I messed up.
Heh, heh, heh.
Um...
It's okay.
Heh, heh, heh.
Oh.
Hold on.
I need the timing.
This is locked.
Oh, yeah, we need a key.
It's okay, we're getting this out of the way.
Wait, this area is so scary, though.
Okay.
Yeah!
I need a key.
Again.
Oh.
Shoot.
Where's the aim?
Oh.
Dang it.
Come on.
Yeah!
Gonna run out of health packs here.
Reload?
Thank you.
I shall, I shall, I shall.
Oh!
Shoot!
I still got it.
Into the wall.
I bet she doesn't even know how to roll.
Take that, mister.
Oh, you can just use bandages.
That's so true.
I forgot.
Thank you.
Yeah, you know what?
We're gonna...
We're gonna do that for now.
Unless we get really low on health.
Happy 9 years.
Thank you!
I don't know why I said thank you.
Yeah, happy 9...
Yeah, it's my...
9-year Metal Gear anniversary.
I had a feeling that was gonna be there.
Come on.
Yeah!
Wait, I wonder if I can punch it.
I keep shooting though.
Okay, that one's a little far.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, I feel so powerful every time.
I feel so powerful every time.
Yeah!
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Hahaha.
Haha.
There's a door.
Reload.
Yeah, I'm a badass.
Oh, I still can't.
Even from the other side?
Okay.
But we did it!
Oh!
Party!
We did it!
Yeah!
And we got a first aid kit.
Um,
will night heat resistant suit work here?
Um, will night heat resistant suit work here?
It is for heat related tasks.
Will this work?
I mean...
Oh, hell yeah!
Yippee!
Oh, okay, nice.
You're pretty good.
Thanks!
Whoa!
Nice!
I'll take it.
I'll take it, I'll take it, I'll take it.
Beep.
Okay.
Very good.
Alright.
More bullets.
Okay.
This is like the fury.
Oh!
Okay.
Is my suit gonna get like too hot or something?
Is it gonna be like, oh no!
I can't handle it anymore!
Lucky.
This looks like a boss room.
Ugh, listening to stream while at work.
Good luck with work!
Sci-fi!
What's this?
Oh.
Jesse here.
Over.
Shit, there's no signal down here.
Oh, okay.
There was nobody in the room, but my instincts told me it was a perfect place for a trap.
That's what I said!
I knew it!
Oh my god, no.
No, no, no.
Oh my gosh, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
I pressed the wrong button instead of...
I pressed heal instead of...
I pressed heal instead of roll.
Okay.
We have our gun.
Let's attach this.
We have...
We have dodge.
We have our roll.
We have our rolls.
We got our buttons.
We've got...
Everything we need.
Okay!
Ikimasu.
There was nobody in the room, but...
Alright.
Shop.
Wow!
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
No!
You bastard!
I think I better die here.
That one was so dirty though.
It came out right next to me.
I didn't even have a...
I didn't even have time to dodge it because it was right there.
It was right next to me.
I just realized also my cursor has been on the screen this whole time, hasn't it?
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
In fact, it might be better to do the first aid kit instead.
Oh,
was it there?
Oh.
I thought it was there.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Anyway.
Okay.
Okay, so it's the top one first, and then this one over here, and then this one over here, and there's one... two in the corner down there.
There was nobody in the room, but...
Turret store.
And I can run away.
Oh my gosh.
The dodge has a...
has a bit of a cool down.
No save spot!
Oh my god.
They just shoot through the...
There's no save spot!
They shoot through the...
through the things.
That's tough.
This is tricky.
Yeah, there's no cover.
Okay, yeah.
I just can't get hit.
Okay.
There was nobody in the room.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh!
I thought it would be over!
I don't know why I thought that!
Okay, I think it's just this one then.
Nothing else has popped up.
Oh my god, dodge!
What the...
We can...
Oh, I can shoot through here then too then.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh, I'm out of bullets!
No!
Boss defeated!
Reloads!
That's what I needed just then.
I needed the reloads gun automatically in this very moment.
That might be better though.
I want the camouflage, but I think the...
I think the...
Gunslinger might be better for me.
Oops, sorry.
Enemies further than 4 yards can't detect you if you're flat against a wall.
The camo seems OP though.
Why gunslinger?
You can't...
I feel like... okay.
I feel like the...
Gunslinger is also going to...
hurt me.
Okay, this is the reason why.
Because when you reload, you can't move.
And so if I just am trying to dodge something, but I don't need to reload immediately, but it automatically starts reloading, it's going to just like...
keep me there.
You know?
So I think it will actually...
hurt me more than it will help me.
Dodge.
Okay.
We did it.
And let's grab some better...
Okay, there's bullets in here.
But there better also be...
Someone was like...
Can't you just know when you have to reload?
Yeah, but I'm also focusing on other things.
And sometimes I'm not looking at my gun.
Okay.
But I will reload right now.
I only have... They didn't give me a single health pack.
That's so messed up.
It was my birthday.
Curry Ninja!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday...
to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Curry Ninja.
Happy birthday...
to you.
Happy birthday Curry Ninja.
There we go.
Let's run all the way back.
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Wait, where was that other room?
Is it all the way up here?
There was a... no, wait.
Wrong way?
Okay.
The one that had the other key necessary?
La la la la la.
Nice.
They wouldn't put like another...
Another...
Oh, this is just like a room room.
I'm scared.
Why was this room all locked up though?
What's in here?
Oh!
A mine detector!
Oh sorry, metal detector.
Yippee!
Now we can go through the minefield.
Yes!
Goodbye creepy area.
This area was so creepy.
For no reason.
Why is this area so mysterious?
What's in here?
What am I missing?
Why is it mysterious?
What's in here?
Oh, sorry.
Um...
Let's try the mine detector.
Oh, how does this work?
How does this work?
Oh, I'm s-
Oh no, they don't stay up.
Oh, I can walk in between them?
Oh!
I can't walk in between them.
Um, this is hard.
You guys- Wait, how the heck am I supposed to-
How am I supposed to- How am I supposed to get through?
How am I supposed to get through?
How
am I supposed to get through?
We're all over the mine.
Yeah.
Okay, I think my most viable option was uh...
Nope.
Over here.
Oh my god.
How did this guy get so far through?
What?
How did he get so far?
Oh my gosh, this is stressing me out.
Guys, this is stressing me out a little bit.
He was like hopping over everything.
Um...
Which way?
Wait, do you guys think I should go left or right?
Uh, they're both about the same I think.
Oh gosh!
Oh gosh, I don't know if I can make it through there!
My dumpy's too thick!
Oh my god.
Okay, wait a minute.
Okay.
Maybe...
I think we made it.
What's it say?
Wait, is there...
Oh, there's still some in here, aren't there?
Oh gosh.
Don't do this to me.
Ah!
I want the metal!
Oh
my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna get it.
Is it a trap though?
You don't think it's a trap, right?
Maybe down.
No.
Can I squeeze through here?
Maybe.
I'm scared!
Oh, I made it.
I made it, I made it.
Okay.
Maybe down.
I can't see through the tree.
No, our metal!
Okay, I'm gonna have to save as soon as we get it.
I don't even think we went to any height.
I think we just...
Oh my gosh.
I feel like that was close.
Okay.
Let's save.
How do I use it?
Wait, how do I use it again?
Select.
I selected it.
It's not letting me save?
Oh wait.
It's kind of evil that they put some in the trees like that.
Okay, let's go up a little.
Let's go up this way instead.
Oh gosh.
The sound is annoying me.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna lower the volume a little bit.
Oh
gosh.
How do I get through?
You can only pee in a save zone?
What if I pee up here?
What if I pee after I...
I keep pressing C on accident.
Um...
No!
I'm already through though!
I'm in the safe area!
No!
From what I can tell, Gunslinger doesn't make you stop when it reloads.
No way!
Did I...
Did I screw myself out of that then?
Dang it.
No peeing in the minefield.
I can't do it while people are watching.
This one... This area is so...
I can't tell where I can squeeze past and where I can't.
You know?
It's tough.
I think maybe they should have clarified like...
Oh, if you pick the reload, you won't stop to reload.
You know?
Because otherwise I think...
I think more... I think I'm not the only person probably to...
I think I'm not the only person probably to...
assume that, you know?
Oh my gosh, that was close.
I... Oh, I wish the...
range was wider...
for this thing.
It's actually quite...
obnoxious.
not knowing...
where I'm like...
scanning, you know?
Because I have to go so...
because I have to go so...
I'm gonna go down.
No!
Why did you save, you game?
Mines weren't the only threat.
The jungle was home to ferocious hunters.
Are you kidding me?
I noticed the presence of...
Of... of...
Frogs?
Flies?
Uh...
Step on a mine to give me...
fireworks for my birthday.
No!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna say frogs.
Arrowhead frogs.
It's poison.
Lethal.
A single scratch could make me...
croak.
You're kidding me.
You're kidding me right now.
Can I shoot them?
I cannot shoot them.
Why can't I shoot the frogs?
Molotov?
I think the... No!
The mines will explode!
I think the...
No!
The mines will explode!
Oh gosh.
What if I throw the meat?
It won't let me throw the meat.
This is so evil.
Actually.
This game might be the most evil game....
ever.
And they don't even go in like...
patterns.
They're random.
There.
They don't even... Oh my gosh!
They don't even go in like a pattern.
If they do, if's a very long pattern.
I don't think there are mines.
I think... but he said the landmines, right?
You know what?
Okay, I'm just gonna run for it then.
Oh my gosh.
I'm stuck on a tree.
Okay.
Yippee!
Thanks.
We made it somehow.
Somehow.
Somehow we made it.
Oh, never mind.
Back to the mines.
No!
I don't like the mines.
I need my little canary.
Actually it was super easy, barely an inconvenience.
Shut up!
Shut up, you!
I don't think it saved after the... after when I got here, so...
Oh gosh.
But what's up there?
Is there like another path up here?
Wait.
I'm trying to... click on... oh, why did I just do that?
Oh, it won't show my cursor.
Never mind.
Imagine if the mines were plastic.
I don't think that would make a difference.
What if I...
go up here?
Is there anything?
Am I just being crazy?
I might be crazy.
That scared me.
You know what?
Let's just go.
I don't care if there's a secret.
Are there mines in here?
There's no sign.
Maybe I'm safe.
Welcome to the jungle.
Oh, I think I'm safe now.
Oh...
Oh gosh.
I think I'm gonna get lost in here though.
You got your firework.
Yeah, there you go, Joshua.
There you go.
Oh!
While wandering through that jungle, I found something.
Or rather, someone.
Someone?
Who the hell is that?
I saw the rotten remains of an escaping prisoner.
It had a note.
If you're reading this note, then I'm dead.
My name is Henry Stanley.
Stanley.
And I was imprisoned for a crime I didn't commit.
That's just like us.
Damn, just like me.
After escaping from my cell, I ran away through the sewers then ended up in the Alpha Building.
Just like us!
I finally managed to leave that damn building.
Just like us.
But now I'm lost in this tropical hell.
I've spent thirty years trying to leave this damn jungle.
Thirty years?!
But no luck.
I'm old, and my strength is fading.
I won't last long.
These are my last words.
These were his last words.
Other than the note, there was a compass, but the needle was missing.
A broken compass was useless, so I didn't take it.
You should've...
What do you mean you didn't take it?
Can I...
We won't be like that guy.
This... this jungle is the easiest thing ever.
A broken compass is useless.
So I didn't take it.
Okay.
I think we're almost out.
Oh, shoot.
These are my last words.
No!
Wait.
Now the guy's gonna be...
Another corpse.
No.
It's the same guy.
I searched the corpse.
It was also rotting and gripping another compass.
The needle was also missing.
Someone or something in this jungle was stealing compass needles.
There was a secret pocket in his ragged clothes.
Secret pocket!
Within, I found a note.
If you only found this note...
... then someone else stole my other note.
Stole my other note!
Another note?
Oh
my god, this game is so stupid.
That's such a good gag, actually.
That's actually such a good gag.
No...
I love it.
I think we're heading back to where we came from.
I think.
Here's my note.
The other one got stolen.
Who's stealing?
Who's out here stealing notes?
We don't have any notes in our inventory, so it definitely wasn't us.
Okay.
Looking for a third corpse.
Are we gonna see him right now?
A third corpse?
Fuck.
That jungle was more dangerous than I expected.
Wait, I've searched everywhere, though.
It was rotting, too.
Like the others.
It had a compass on it.
Don't tell me.
The needle was missing.
Exactly.
Could it be that you were running into the same corpse over and over again?
I commend you for coming to the same place.
Monty Python rope.
I don't use it.
I passed by seven times to confirm it.
I was wandering in circles.
The damn jungle was toying with me.
I had to orient myself somehow or I'd end up spending thirty years in that maze of trees.
I tried to direct myself by watching the stars.
The stars.
But the damn top down view only let me see the trees and ground.
So I had to find another way to gain direction.
Hmm.
The compass!
We finally took the compass!
We could use anything as a needle, right?
What the hell is that?
Oh!
What the...
The rusty wire?
Oh my gosh!
I think you're a genius!
Ew!
The wire wouldn't have been magnetized.
How did you expect it to work?
Modern compasses don't need the wire to be magnetized.
Just turns out the compass wasn't modern.
Oh.
So it didn't work.
Dang.
Oh.
That's not where we were!
I was looking at the compass, thinking of how to make it work.
Wait!
When something caught my eye.
In the middle of the grass.
Something glimmered under the pale moonlight.
The corpse.
In my peripheral vision.
I noticed I was not the only one to spot it.
The corpse.
Bird!
Oh my god, no.
Why is this bro so loud?
What?
Why did he take it?
I'm gonna punch that bird.
Wait, um...
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, shoot!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Okay.
We have to go far away.
And then we have to shoot him.
Dang it.
Um, meat!
He wants the meat.
Ravens are friends of small shiny things.
Not meat.
Uh...
Coin!
Shinny things.
Hey, hey, hey!
No, no!
I think we have to lead him over.
I think we have to...
How do I...
Oh!
The needle!
Yippee!
Alright!
Now how do we use it?
Weast.
East.
Oh.
Wait, do I go west?
Now I go south.
Okay.
Go south.
It's telling me the way, everybody.
It's telling me the way.
East.
This is definitely how compasses work.
South.
Oh!
This is where we were before!
Weast.
Okay.
Make sure we don't get attacked.
Do I need to heal after?
I don't think so.
We just...
That was strange.
Weast.
Oh, shoot!
Wait!
Did that just ruin my...
Okay, no.
We're good.
Oh!
Vivicore, thanks for the five-gifter!
Oh, thank you!
Nice.
More bullets?
Okay.
Um...
South.
Oh my gosh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
I'm gonna heal.
I'm gonna heal real quick.
There we go.
Let's just heal real quick!
Let's just get our...
Let's just get our health back up and pretty and nice, and...
Ooh!
Sorry, I have my TV on.
I'm watching advertisements.
Okay, let's go.
Yeah, you want some of that?
We're going south again.
There's no guys.
Curious...
We're going east!
Hi X300, thanks for the five gifted!
Okay.
We're going...
Okay, we're going north, sorry.
I wasn't...
Oh my gosh.
I know to reload!
Run away!
East!
Oh my gosh.
This is like the longest area ever.
I'm gonna run out of bullets at this rate.
Wait, what was it?
East?
Okay.
Nice suit!
Oh my gosh, we're probably gonna have to face this as like the boss of this area, aren't we?
Like a big one or something.
Probably.
North!
Ooh, that was close.
East!
Like a big boss?
I crack myself up.
We're going south!
Wait, can I save in these areas?
Actually, now that I think about it...
Nice.
It's probably just good to have a little bit of an area, you know?
Okay.
Uh...
South!
These areas, like, kind of mess with me.
I'm like, is it safe or not?
West.
Okay.
Weest!
Oh my god, that was close.
This thing is fast.
So...
Weest.
I saw a video with YumeiTara talking about Metal Gear.
Is this the original Metal Gear on NES?
Or is this something else?
This is a parody of Metal Gear, actually.
But thanks for watching!
Mystery area...
Colonel!
Why is this a mystery area?
What's here?
We missed the other mystery even!
We missed the mystery before...
What could the mystery here be?
Should I call the radio?
Let's try.
Colonel!
Escape vehicle.
I sound so tired.
I'll try.
I'll try, Colonel.
You still here?
Yep.
Haha.
Does anyone know?
I'm so curious, like what you're supposed to do in this area.
What do I have?
Have eyeballs?
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
The sunglasses at night?
Don't do anything, you guys.
Punch the tree?
Oh!
What?
Oh my god.
That actually worked.
Platoon!
Attention!
Are you ladies the new recruits?
Yes sir!
Fuck you, the saddest bunch I've ever met.
And I've seen stacks of shit taller than you are.
Saddest bunch I've ever met.
You think you're my soul because you stuck your dicks in god knows what hole?
I'm going to beat you shit stacks into weapons of war!
Even if it kills you!
Where are you from, boy?
From Minnesota, sir.
Minnesota?
Only two things come out of Minnesota.
Men and soda.
I don't see you bubbling, so you must be a min.
What's a min, sir?
Do I look like a scientist to you, pissant?
Sir, no sir.
You're not worth an urban dictionary entry, shit stain.
Hahaha.
What do you do at night, scumbag?
I sleep, sir.
Sleep!
Will they see me?
Well, excuse me, princess.
Does she need a wheel map?
Oh my god, what a reference.
Excuse me, princess.
We train.
We go the extra mile.
When do we sleep, sir?
During your break time, your highness.
But sir, it's a 15 minute break.
Then sleep fast, fuck!
Hahaha.
Yes, sir.
What the fuck happened to your eyebrows?
They're shaped, sir.
They're shaped?
Are you kidding me?
Do you think they'll see me?
Are you the bitch of the yard?
Sir, it's personal hygiene, sir.
Oh.
Sir, I saw someone behind the fence.
No you didn't.
They're gone!
Next group!
Oh, they're all coming back.
I guess I'm from Minnesota.
Attention!
Are you ladies the new recruits?
They're back, they're back.
Fuck, you're the saddest bunch I've ever met.
And I've seen stacks of shit taller than you are.
You think you're macho because you stuck your dicks in god knows what hole.
I'm going to beat you shit stacks into weapons of war.
Even if it kills you.
Oh, I think I missed it.
Where are you from, boy?
I think I missed whatever that was.
I thought it was going to be an actual alert.
Oh no!
Only two things come out of Minnesota.
Min and soda.
Why is everybody from Minnesota?
I don't see you bubbling, so you must be a min.
What's a min, sir?
Do I look like a scientist to you, pissant?
I arrived at what looked like the exit of a barracks.
Pissant.
What looked like the what?
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Oh.
Mike!
Are you going to open the door?
Are you going to open the damn door or not?
Hold on, I'm opening it.
My instinct told me the gate was going to open and a truck was going to leave.
I could sneak onto the truck and get far away from here.
His instincts.
Oh, here I go.
See you later.
Skip!
Yo, Mike!
Mike!
What's up?
Hold on.
I need to verify the departure permit.
Fuck, Mike!
Hurry up!
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I can get in.
There you go.
Sneak into the truck.
That was so easy.
Yeah, yeah.
I did it.
Yo, Mike!
Mike!
Can I leave now?
Negative.
Negative?
The lieutenant canceled the delivery.
No way.
You'll have to come back in.
Oh, holy fuck.
No!
Oh my gosh.
No, we just left.
Please.
Ow!
Oh my gosh.
Stage complete.
There are two more secrets.
Wait, I got one secret.
Or, well, I know the tree was a secret, but what was the other secret?
Interesting.
The barracks.
The trip was shorter than expected.
Oh my god.
Instead of heading away, I ended up inside the compound.
How is this happening?
The ground was muddy, beaten lifeless by countless people.
There were countless combat boots.
There's gonna be tons of guys here.
There were sandbags and boxes everywhere.
Everywhere.
Whoa.
He was a jerk.
I heard Mike getting off the truck and talking to the other Mike.
Why are they all named Mike?
Hey Mike, what the hell happened?
Someone screwed up and loaded the wrong stuff.
Useless fuckwads.
Ooh.
They reported that they'll get the correct stuff loaded soon.
Okay.
Sounds like a nap is in order.
No can do.
North parking lot.
233.
Okay.
These guys have such potty mouths.
We got another truck.
Our instinct.
North gate without being seen.
Okay.
Alright, let's go to the north gate.
Where's my chloroform?
Oh.
Let's select you.
And I guess we don't need that anymore.
But we'll just do the bandage for now.
Okay.
I'm gonna get this guy.
If I can.
I don't know his pattern yet.
Are you gonna walk down now?
Oh.
Never mind.
I still got him.
I was gonna chloroform him, but I forgot to press space.
He doesn't have anything?
You useless?
Binoculars.
Interesting.
Alright.
That's all the good stuff.
Doctor's gonna be so mad.
I mean...
Even if I had put him to sleep, he still would have gotten to...
Die truck.
If I put him to sleep, he still probably would have...
You know?
Would have gotten to...
He would have been like, I fell asleep.
No...
Oh my gosh.
I had to be careful not to be seen.
Oh my god.
Did that guy see me?
I pressed...
I just neutralized a soldier, but I couldn't leave him in sight.
I just...
Those platoons could pass by, see him, and raise the alarm.
But I pressed space!
So I made sure to carry the soldiers I neutralized, hiding them elsewhere, out of sight of those patrols.
I pressed space!
I knocked guards inside buildings.
Well, hold on.
Oh, inside buildings?
Okay.
It said press X.
Yeah, but I wasn't trying to do that.
I didn't want to punch him.
I pressed space because I wanted a chloroform.
Oh my god.
They're not coming this way, right?
You guys aren't understanding my point!
I know it said press X, but I want it to stop.
I pressed space instead of X!
You're not understanding my point.
It is space though, right?
To use the chloroform.
They're not going to notice the blood, right?
We choose not to understand.
What if I take all these guys out one by one?
No
one can use.
Yeah!
Meat, cheese, fries, mince, thighs.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, oh shit.
They're coming.
There they are.
All those guys.
And there they go.
Wow, they're kind of fast though, aren't they?
No one ever uses the bathroom.
They'll never notice.
And he's got nothing on him.
Stingy.
Oh shoot.
Nice.
Hey you.
Thank you.
What's this?
Bullet slot.
Nice!
Oh gosh, this one's gonna be tricky though.
I think.
Because those guys are gonna come back!
Oh no.
Oh no no no no no!
Okay, actually, this works.
Oh wow!
We haven't gotten any depleted uranium in a while.
More bullet slot.
Okay.
But they don't come in here, right?
They don't come this side.
Okay.
We'll wait for them to come around.
To do their little round, and then we'll get the guy on the right.
Okay.
And then they're gonna go up.
I think.
I think they're gone.
Probably.
Um.
Uh.
Oh.
Like I need a gun.
There we go.
Okay, perfect.
Cool.
But we can't let him die.
Don't worry!
We won't let him die.
Oh.
He's fine.
Oh shit.
You guys.
I think it's over.
Um.
I think I found a loophole.
Hey.
Why are there so many guys?
Call Colonel.
I guess.
Colonel.
Still there?
Affirmative.
Where are you?
I'm still in the compound.
What?
Weren't you escaping in a truck?
What the hell are you doing back there?
I snuck onto a truck, but it went backwards and returned to the compound.
Oh damn it, Fox.
Colonel.
I know about another truck that's going to leave in a while.
I'll call you later.
Call you later.
I'll run out.
Are you streaming tomorrow?
It's my birthday, so I wanted to know if I could get a chew in case you are it.
What is this request?
A chew?
Um.
I think I'm streaming tomorrow.
I have to double check my calendar.
I have to make my streaming schedule.
Sorry.
I don't know why I'm coughing.
Oh.
Jacker here.
Who the hell?
Ghost.
Do you copy?
Who the hell are you?
Jacker?
Huh?
Who are you?
Where is Ghost?
I'm Ghost.
I don't know who that is.
I think you got the wrong channel.
Oops.
Ugin must have been tampering with the communicator.
Damn geeks.
Over and out.
What the?
Who are you?
Just in case though.
Just in case I'm not streaming.
I'm pretty sure I am.
But just in case I'm not.
Happy birthday Michi's thigh.
Wait.
Michi's fries.
Men's thighs.
Right?
Thank you.
Where is Ghost?
I am Ghost.
Wait.
Are they coming back?
There's so many guys here.
No way.
Inside that barrack there were some guards.
I didn't see them because they were sitting behind some bunk beds.
Slipping out of guard duty.
Or running around the compound.
Or worse.
I don't know if I'm in trouble or not.
But thanks to my extraordinary hearing acuity, I could hear their conversation.
Okay, when you enter the dungeon, two skeletons with rusty axes block your way.
Are they playing D&D?
The eerie red light that glimmers in their eye sockets watches you fixedly.
What do you do?
I load my elven bowl and shoot.
Hang on.
Are you really shooting an arrow at a monster that can't believe?
What do you think will happen?
That the arrow gets stuck between its ribs and slows it down?
Man, why not?
Someone just walked in.
Fuck.
It must be the drill sergeant.
Quick.
Hide yourselves.
You guys, I'm in trouble.
Dang it.
Wait.
I'm far away, aren't I?
No way.
No!
My gosh.
Oh, hello.
It's caught on the door.
There you go.
What if I destroy their beds even?
Oh, I can!
Yeah!
Destroy it all!
No one's sleeping in here tonight!
You can move in chloroforming.
You can?
Okay.
Good to know.
Thank you.
Oh, they're coming.
I just... Let's just restart.
I didn't even get shot.
I don't know what happened.
Oh, wait.
They're gonna come out.
They're gonna come.
They're gonna be right here.
There they are.
And there they go.
Okay.
Oh, I bled out?
Oh.
There it is.
Nice.
Was that karma for destroying all their beds, maybe?
You think?
I think it was karma for destroying all their beds.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh.
That was insane.
Wait.
Why aren't they leaving?
They're all just hanging around out here.
Uh-oh.
Oh...
Oh, no.
Leave!
No way.
Why aren't they leaving?
I guess let me see what happens if I go out.
This area is kind of painful, isn't it?
They were just camping me.
Okay.
Okay, I have to wait for them to go.
Oh my gosh.
Why did you just stand there?
Once you're caught, you can't really get out of an alert.
Like it's either...
The game is just don't get caught.
It's not like a...
It's not like Metal Gear.
It's really just don't get caught.
Okay.
I don't know where they are though, so I'll just wait for the red arrows.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, the binoculars?
That's so true.
We haven't seen them...
Use them to see further, unless it's backwards.
What?
Sticking to the wall camouflage thing?
Well, that's the thing.
Is I've been sticking to some stuff.
And I think it's only when he like lays flat, right?
Because...
Because there were some times...
Where...
Like...
Like this...
This wouldn't count, right?
You know, like...
This doesn't count.
I think he has to lay flat against the wall.
Which makes it a little tricky.
And also against...
Not certain...
Like this wouldn't work.
Right?
I think it's only walls.
I think I...
Scammed myself.
I think I scammed myself truly.
Okay, let's see.
Let's wait for these guys to go down...
And around.
Okay, here they are.
And there they...
Go?
Oh my gosh.
No!
I lost the timing because that guy.
The Angry Doritos.
Okay, don't turn around.
Where is he?
I don't know.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Once I get the next guy too, I'll save.
Good.
There they go.
There they run away.
There we go, there we go.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh.
I'm Ghost!
What is this a reference to?
Boogan.
Pull
this.
Okay.
Destroy.
Okie dokie.
Now I'm gonna save.
Cool.
Alright, that's a good place to save.
Actually...
I was gonna say I could go empty it like right away, but then what would be the point, you know?
I don't understand this.
Oh!
Interesting.
That guy stands covered by a...
Ohoho!
Here they come.
And I can see when they're coming!
Interesting.
Whoa!
This part is very tricky.
I'll be honest.
It ain't easy.
But you're intriguing.
There they go!
You can see their running path even.
I just noticed.
Yes!
Okay.
Okie dokie.
Okay, nice.
But you can't use it indoors, which kind of sucks.
Only outdoors.
And our guy...
Once he turns around...
Oh, he's heading... Okay.
I think I can get his butt now.
Okay!
Whoever taught me that you can move while doing the chloroform?
I owe you.
Binoculars aren't usually useful indoors, Minto.
Look, okay.
You have a valid point.
If I go inside this room...
I kind of want to use the bathroom though.
Okay, I'm going to use the bathroom.
In game, not in real life.
I want to save.
I want to save where I'm at.
There we go, okay.
Okay.
There we go.
Hold on.
Don't be a wierd.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
We let them run away.
Yeah.
How do I get this guy?
No, I wanted to screenshot it.
Oh my god.
Oh see, like now it works.
See how I'm pressed against the box?
Maybe I can get him right now.
Oh, I'm bleeding out.
I'm bleeding out.
Ah!
And...
Oh, shoot.
V...
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
You guys, I think I'm done, though.
Never mind.
Inside that barrack, there were some guards.
I didn't see them because they were sitting behind some bunk beds.
Slipping out of guard duty or running around the compound were worse.
But thanks to my extraordinary hearing acuity, I could hear their conversation.
Aha!
Okay, when you enter the dungeon...
Okay, I'm gonna skip this.
...two skeletons with rusty...
Someone just walked in.
Fuck.
It must be the drill sergeant.
Okay.
The ghost call is a reference to one of the dev's other games, Ghost.
A Metroidvania.
Ah, I see, I see.
Um, for this part...
I will save, actually.
Because... well, can I?
Oh, I can't.
Okay, just kidding.
Um... I... I want to get the stuff.
But if I walk past them...
I can't get that other box over there, right?
Or I just can't touch them, maybe.
There's a bathroom right there!
As I walked in, I ran into a soldier.
Wait, no, no, no, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Oh, am I good?
Wait.
I think I'm good.
You guys, I think I'm...
Wait, but I skipped a scene!
Because I thought I was dead.
I skipped a scene.
I thought I was dead.
But now I don't know what's going...
Um...
I thought I was dead.
I didn't want to... I didn't want to watch it and then die, you know?
A little last party.
I just saved the game.
I'll just watch the screen.
I'll just watch it later on YouTube.
Hold on.
If I load last party...
Oh, wait.
Oh, it actually did work.
No!
But I have to redo this part!
Oh, come on.
That's so lame.
My master of stealthiness.
That was a master of stealth, you guys!
But you know what?
I guess this is fine.
Preserve the game, you know?
Self-sabotage.
It's okay.
We can do this part.
It's no problem.
It's all good.
We weren't that far behind.
I think I actually went and saved, like, after this.
At the actual... I thought it would do the actual party that I was in earlier.
I went and saved at the actual party.
Weird.
In fact, we can go now.
Wait.
Yeah, because we still have the full party here.
Oh, no, no, no.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Oh, here they come.
So there's like two groups of guys running around.
Party override.
Yeah, okay.
So the D&D guys, we just can't go up there at all.
I've learned my lesson.
I thought maybe even if I like...
What's the word?
If I try not to touch them or anything, you know?
I thought maybe the first time I accidentally, like, touched them.
But I didn't.
So now I learned my lesson.
Don't be greedy.
Something something.
Mei Ling was right.
Holy moly.
Okay.
They don't even suspect that...
Someone goes missing every time.
They don't even suspect that a guard goes missing.
The guys running, they're just too busy running, you know?
Okay.
Here we go.
All right.
But I can at least take the uranium.
I can at least get this.
Oh.
We'll take that.
And wait for the guys to pass again.
At the end, you guys don't trigger a full-on alert?
Are you sure?
I'm too nervous.
What's in that crate?
What if it's something I need?
I can't shoot all of them because...
They would get injured and then I'll lose the game.
I can't heal all of them.
I mean, I have five health kits, but that's for me.
I'm greedy.
Molotov?
No.
If I kill the guys, I lose the game.
I actually game over if you...
If you kill people, you actually lose the game.
I can't save here.
I tried before.
See?
So...
I could...
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
Waiting for them to leave?
I'll go save in another room.
Maybe...
What if I can save here?
It worked.
OK.
Let's see.
How do we want to do this?
You don't enjoy the killing all that much.
Alexis, welcome back.
Thank you.
Let's just have this on hand, I suppose.
And...
Watch there be nothing of value in...
In...
That box.
There's going to be nothing of value, probably.
How do they know it's me?
It's not like I just died.
Oh.
No.
I didn't...
Oh my god.
Wait.
Where am I supposed to take this guy?
Oh, shoot.
The building is fa...
Oh no!
Guys, we are not going to make it.
Escape.
Escaping prisoner.
Stay back.
I got the star for it.
What do I do?
What do I do with that guy?
What do I do with him?
I don't think they'll see me here.
Maybe I hide him behind the crates instead?
I don't think they'll see him behind the crates.
Like right here?
Maybe they won't notice.
Let's see.
Let's see if they notice me.
Alright, washroom man.
You're getting washroomed.
Let me use the body.
What?
Oh!
The guy!
The guy that I left behind the thing.
Oh my gosh, so I actually can't save.
That's messed up.
That's so messed...
What?
It won't even let me pee here?
In the bathroom?
This is messed up.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
How am I...
What am I...
What am I supposed to do?
I think I'm supposed to grab him.
Okay, let's wait for them to pass again.
Let's wait for them to pass again.
Oops.
Alright, here we go.
La, la, la, la, la.
Yeah, we're gonna put him...
Oh.
I think this guy's gonna see me though.
Please, please, go.
Shawwww!
Alright!
Yippee!
And we'll wait for them to run by again.
Whenever they come by.
There they are.
I knew they'd be soon.
Okay.
And then this guy's walking past.
But we're gonna wait for him to turn.
Or go down.
I think he goes down.
Nevermind.
That's okay though.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Calm yourself.
Just two dudes sleeping in a bathroom?
No.
Three dudes sleeping in a bathroom.
Hahahaha.
Add more dudes.
Perfect.
Can I go into this truck?
Okay.
Oh, that's right.
That's the guy that's hammered up there.
Okay.
There they are.
We'll wait for them to leave.
Uh-uh.
Leave.
Is there anything in here?
Okay.
No.
Alright.
Now we can get this cutscene.
Huh?
Oh, okay.
As I walked in, I ran into a soldier.
A soldier.
The guy was so hammered that he confused me with one of his buddies.
Hey, Mike.
Oh.
A Mike.
Hey.
Mike.
You want a drink?
No, Mike.
Uh, no thank you.
I don't drink when I escape.
Hold on.
You're not Mike.
No.
I'm Fox.
Oh, my God.
Shut up, Jesse Fox.
Jesse Fox.
Yes, you're Mike.
You're the prisoner?
I would escape too if I could.
Oh, my God.
Jesse.
Why?
To see my daughter.
It turns out that he had a little daughter who he hadn't seen in three years.
Aww.
Every year he requests leave to go see her.
And every year his drill sergeant rejects him.
Drill sergeant.
I'm gonna kill that guy.
So, in a week, the daughter was turning six.
No.
And Mike requested leave again.
And yet, again, the drill sergeant rejected him.
That daughter's not even gonna know who that guy is.
Which was why he was drowning his sorrows.
Aww.
It's so sad.
Until he knocked himself out.
Yay.
Oh, wait.
Whoa.
Sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
How do I escape from this?
Okay.
And now, I'm gonna go to the other room.
Help Mike get permission slip stamped.
Permission request.
It's a stealth game and he's a stealth dad.
I'm shy.
Oh.
Needs to be sealed by the instruction sergeant.
Okay.
Sweet dreams, Mike.
We're gonna help Mike out.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, there's another bathroom.
There's a lot of bathrooms in this area.
I guess that's very kind of them, because...
I ran into a guard as I went in.
No!
Oh.
He was urinating.
Ew.
Please don't tell me you pissed that guard off while he was urinating.
Oh.
They couldn't.
Someone beat me to it.
What?
What the hell are you doing, scumbag?
He's peeing!
Did you wash your hands?
It's the most important mission you've had all game, man.
Yeah.
Are you touching your dick with your dirty hands?
How can you be such a pig?
Hands are lost before, not after peeing.
What?
Yes, sir.
Why did you stop peeing, scumbag?
Sir, I ran out of pee, sir.
What a pussy!
Who do you think you are, a fucking civil?
A soldier continues peeing even if his balls are empty.
Now get the hell out of here!
Sir, yes, sir.
This guy is so loud.
Sergeant, there's someone behind you.
Fuck, soldier, did I tell you to look behind me?
This guy sucks.
Then why the hell are you looking behind me?
Here, you don't look, listen, or speak unless I tell you to do it.
Pee is stored in the balls.
Understood?
Sir, yes, sir.
Pee is stored in the...
That damn drill sergeant acted tough with his men.
But he ended up crying like a baby with me.
Cry like a little baby...
Oh!
I'm actually fighting him.
Who the fuck are you?
And where the hell is your uniform?
Um...
Stolen.
It's been stolen, sir.
Someone broke into my locker and took it.
And who the hell was it?
It was...
Mike.
It was... Mike, sir.
Damn, you son of a bitch!
Which one?
You might need to narrow it down, scumbag.
It was...
It's all ripped and from Texas.
Just like me, sir.
The way...
Fuck!
You're from Texas?
Only two things come from Texas.
Tex and ash.
Turn home, you assholes!
Which one are you, boy?
I don't see any ash smears.
But I definitely see a shit stain.
But, sir, Texas exports propane accessories.
Shut the fuck up, shit smear!
Propane and propane accessories.
I'm not a shit smear.
Yes, you are.
No, no, I'm not.
Hold on, Mr. Fox.
Didn't you say it was the drill sergeant who ended up crying like a baby?
You're contradicting yourself.
It was you.
It was me.
Sergeant, execute this liar.
Yes, sir.
What?
I died.
I died because I'm a liar.
I guess we go fight the drill sergeant.
I guess.
Do we have to do this fight?
We have to because we have to get it...
I ran into a guard as I went in.
We have to get our thing approved.
Or Mike's thing approved.
I guess.
Who the fuck are you?
And where the hell is your...
Um, okay.
My uniform was...
We have to make it so that the drill sergeant cries.
We have to make it so he cries.
He cries.
Um...
If I say I lost it, I feel he's gonna get mad at me.
I think laundry?
Let's try laundry.
In the laundry, sir.
And what in the hell is laundry?
What is your uniform doing in the laundry?
It was dirty, sir.
Are you kidding me?
Since when the clothes have to be clean?
The hands have to be clean?
Because he put it in the laundry once he got a job, sir.
Why do we keep talking about Texas?
Fuck!
You're from Texas?
Only two things come from Texas.
Oh, no.
I think we messed up.
Charcoal and assholes.
We can't bring up Texas, you guys, because we start crying.
I don't see ash smears, but I definitely see a shit stain.
We can't talk about Texas.
Sir, Texas exports propane accessories.
Okay.
Shut the fuck up.
We can't talk about Texas.
We'll cry.
We'll cry, you guys.
Now, Texas is the automatic fail.
Wait.
I'm just curious about this.
It almost looks like an area.
Oh.
It's not.
Okay.
Are they not still running around?
Did we win?
I ran into a guard.
I think our best bet was honestly it getting... stolen.
Right?
But we haven't done Lost yet either.
Let's just try it.
I think he's gonna make fun of us.
In Texas!
Don't say Texas.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
Um... stolen.
Stolen.
Uh, it was... clue?
What's loyalty?
Clue.
What's clue?
We have a clue.
In Texas!
In Te- arm?
He was born in Texas.
You'll never escape the Tex- what's the arm?
Without one arm.
Are you kidding me, scumbag?
There's no such thing as a one-armed soldier here!
There is!
All you maggots barely shoot properly with two arms!
What do you mean?
Back in Texas, we can shoot without using any arms.
Fuck!
You're from Texas?
Only two names come to Texas.
Jesse, why do you keep bringing up Texas?
I don't see any ass in here.
Why do you keep bringing up Texas?
Definitely see a shit stain!
Sir, Texas exports.
This guy just brings up Texas un... un...
Unprompted.
Nobody cares where you're from, Jesse.
You're not special.
Oh.
That looks dangerous.
That looks like a bad area.
That looks like a not-so-good area.
I ran into a guard as I wa- Okay.
Alright, we got this.
Who the fuck are you?
And where the hell is your uniform?
Okay.
It was... okay.
If we say double lost, right?
Because he asked- our first one was lost, and he's like, wait, you have a second one.
We say it's lost also.
I can't find it, sir.
I must have lost it.
Oh, no, no, no.
Lost.
I can't find it, sir.
I must have lost it.
You shit for brains!
And do you have a spare one?
Yes, sir!
And where would that crusty-ass spare uniform be?
It's lost.
I can't find it, sir.
I must have lost it.
You shit for brains!
And do you have a spare one?
Yes, sir!
And where would that crusty-ass spare uniform be?
I can't find it, sir.
I must have lost it.
You shit for brains!
And do you have a spare one?
Yes, sir!
And where would that crusty-ass spare uniform be?
I can't find it, sir.
I must have lost it.
You shit for brains!
And do you have a spare one?
Yes, sir!
And where would that crusty-ass spare uniform be?
I can't find it, sir.
I must have lost it.
This is... we'll say it's stolen.
This is endless, eh?
Okay.
Let's try the clue.
Why did you create a time loop?
I'm still curious what loyalty is.
But I think it's gonna be like, oh, I can't say who.
And then he's gonna say, us in Texas, we're loyal.
We still don't know his identity, sir.
But we have a clue.
What clue, you fuck?
We know he was born...
In Texas.
Okay, I'm gonna say the place.
In the same state you were, sir.
So that son of a bitch is from Texas.
Oh my god!
Hold on.
You're telling me you're from Texas?
Only two things come out of Texas.
We got it!
Propane and assholes.
I don't see any propane accessories.
We did it!
Made from a ship.
Fuck you little...
Of course you are.
Look at your brown eyes.
What?
Poopy brown eyes.
My ass is blue!
You sure?
The whole base is talking about your brown eyes.
No!
I'm not!
To avoid confusion in the record, did he have blue or brown eyes, Mr. Fox?
Both.
But now he had black eyes.
One second, bud.
I'll leave this out of the report.
Proceed.
Just as he started to tear up, I helped all blue eyes kiss the canvas.
We turned it against him.
Boss defeated.
Yippee!
Oh, I mean...
Freeze, or I'll shoot.
What the hell are you doing, scumbag?
Oh!
Aiming at you with my weapon.
Fuck, soldier, did I tell you to aim your weapon at me?
Jesse's full of power.
No, sir.
Then why the hell are you aiming your fucking weapon at me?
Here you don't look, listen, or speak.
Unless I tell you to do it.
Understood?
Oh, my God.
Yes, sir.
Did you wash your hands before aiming your weapon at me, scumbag?
No, sir.
Fuck, how can you be such a pig?
Get the hell out of here.
Sir, yes, sir.
Yeah, get out of here, stupid.
Um, can I get this?
I couldn't stamp the form until I found an ink pad.
Or a tampon.
A what?
Jesse?
Jesse what?
Okay.
So we have to find an ink pad.
Except...
I hope not the ladder.
I hope not.
What a Texas-style uno reverse.
Oh, what's that?
I know, right?
That was kind of...
Oh, shit.
Um, you guys...
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
That was close.
Oh, shit.
And we're gonna take him out.
Yeah.
We found the stamp.
I entered one of the barracks, I saw that it was different from the others.
First off, it had its own urinal.
That's strange.
Moreover, it had an office desk.
That's not as strange.
I figured it was the drill sergeant's quarters.
I had plenty of time because I was sure he was still indisposed in the bathroom.
Nice.
Which means... I'm level 6!
Die hard.
Increase your max HP.
Oh wait, your max HP is increased by 50%.
The gun deals 30% more damage.
Die hard or lethal weapon.
I feel like die hard would be better, right?
To get my max HP... up?
I think this one is better.
Oh my god, I used his toilet.
Got more bullets.
Perfect.
Beep!
Yay!
Okay, let's go return this to our buddy.
Once these guys run away.
Did you wash your hands before saving?
Can I jump into any of these trucks now?
Okay.
I also noticed that there's a way to go up.
That's exactly what I was worried about!
Fragment!
Did you wash your hands before you save?
Sir, yes sir!
Let's go deliver this to Mike.
Mike?
Mark?
Wait, what's their names?
Mike.
Casey!
Thanks for the gift!
Yippee!
Oh, I get a special thing for...
I get an extra body!
For helping him!
Mwah!
Thank you, mister.
Okay.
Okay, they're coming.
They're coming, they're coming, they're going, they're going, they're going.
Okay.
Nice.
And they're gone.
And...
All my potties are...
They're all... Yeah, okay.
I'm just gonna save real quick.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, um, let's...
There we go.
I can go up.
As you can see here.
I can go upwards.
And there he was.
The bastard with a machine gun.
Blocking my way to the north gate.
But, I didn't fight him until I got some grenades.
Oh, okay.
So we leave.
Oh, uh, and we hide.
Did you wash your hands before you touched that potty?
Sir!
Yes, sir!
I'm always washing my hands!
Sir!
Jose, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay, we need grenades now.
We need grenades now, huh?
I think now's the best time to take him.
Oop, oop, oop, oop, oop, oop.
You noticed something?
But he's a little silly.
Nice.
And they're running by.
And they're running by!
And they're running gone.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Wait, wait, um...
Um...
Oh, that was a close one.
Uh, X.
There we go.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run.
I don't have a lot of time.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
No!
You're from Texas!
I think those grenades!
Nice!
Guys, that was a close one.
I'm not gonna lie.
That really stressed me out.
Grenades!
Oh, I can't have any more than eight grenades.
Okay.
Since I gamed that one so hard, I'm gonna actually save.
And then I'm gonna empty it in the...
the...
And let's go back to our chloroform, cause I really like this one.
I'm waiting for the...
Yeah, there we go.
Wait.
Is that them?
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, they like, go through...
Huh?
Did they go down here?
Wait, huh?
Did they go through here?
Why can't I go through here?
Okay.
That's unfair.
For sure.
Can I follow them through?
But I guess we don't need to go down there, huh?
But there was like an extra room.
I think...
I think I can follow them through.
Like...
Or rather, like...
Maybe I should wait and see.
I'm curious, you guys.
Because it looks like a secret area, right?
That doesn't look like the starting area.
I don't remember that line.
Oh, here they come.
Nope.
There was an attempt.
Okay.
Could have gone right from the starting...
Oh!
I see what you mean.
No, no, no, no.
Um...
Yeah, that was a sign.
You're Fox, right?
Oh.
I knew you were going to pass through here sooner or later.
I'm Machine Gun Mike.
Machine Gun Mike.
Are you ready to face me?
Or are you going to run away like a coward?
Run away?
I don't run from dead men.
Then prepare to die.
Machine Gun Mike.
Oh.
Okay.
Interesting.
Hide as much as you want.
Those sandbags are the last victim.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Not good.
This is not good.
Oh.
Ouch.
Holy moly.
And remember...
We...
We increased our HP.
Holy cow.
Yeah, we got to go fast on this one.
Okay.
You're Fox, right?
As much as you want.
Those sandbags will drive you...
Oh my gosh.
I need to...
I need to heal before I...
I think I need to heal before I start this.
Let's just do that right quick.
Once we're fully healed, I'll...
I'll save again.
Okay.
Once we're fully healed, I'll save again.
So we're healed...
We're...
We start at full health.
And then...
We shall go in.
Did you punch the desk?
There was an attempt.
I can punch his bed, though.
Okay.
Now I also have to hope that these guys...
Are not coming.
Let me think about it.
Okay.
I think we're okay.
You're Fox, right?
I knew...
I know I probably won't have time for this, but...
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
No.
No, no!
No!
This is hard!
Because as soon as he loads, I'm trying to heal!
I think I already messed up, you guys.
I think I already messed up.
I've already messed up, you guys!
Roll under it.
Will it work?
I wonder.
I can try.
I'm gonna cry.
If I get stuck on one side, yeah, I'll roll under it.
You're Fox, right?
I'm Jesse Fox!
Hide as much as you want.
Those sandbags won't last.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, see, see, see.
Damn
you, Fox!
Boss defeated!
Oh, son of a bitch!
I'm gonna die!
Somehow we made it.
It was hard because...
Because you have to get so close, I think, to attack him.
So I was having to run, and by the time I was throwing the bombs at him, he was done reloading.
But we're still healing, so actually this is perfect.
Oh, I can't see above me.
Kinda late, but I can't stop laughing in the office.
Let's just wait until we're done healing.
Which
will happen first?
Will I be fully healed?
Or will...
First!
The sandbag...
Didn't even have anything.
I arrived at the northern parking lot.
There were trucks and containers all over the place.
I wanted to hide in the right truck.
Serial number 233 980.
But, Machine Gun Mike could be waiting for me.
Seeking revenge.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, it doesn't work now?
What the fuck?
No, this is...
No!
Come on, thugs!
This is literally just Metal Gear!
Now I go by the name Splash Mike!
Splash Mike!
Because I'm going to splash your entrails all over the place!
You!
Splash Mike!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
What is this?
Rocket launcher!
Oh, I have to also load?
Wait.
I'm actually kind of confused.
Oh, I have to have a rocket.
A rocket.
Okay.
Um, wait.
He's going to destroy the trucks though!
Oh my gosh.
I need him.
Wait.
I need him to destroy stuff so that I can get more...
Um, wait.
I got greedy there.
Um...
Well, shoot.
I arrived at the northern...
But also I have to make sure I get into the right truck.
They made sure that I, like, know the number.
I thought I was going to have to, like, check the numbers, you know?
What the f...
Huh...
Shoot.
Don't get run over.
Oh!
Uh...
Okay.
Then,
destroy this part.
Wait.
What did you just destroy?
Just throw grenades.
Does he know where I am?
There we go.
And then, uh, you can, like, blow this part up too.
Just blow this part up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I also attack you.
I can't tell if, uh, if one part does more damage or not.
You know?
Hmm...
It was a sturdy tank.
It's barely scratched at the paint job.
Yeah.
But why didn't you attack it from behind?
Oh.
It's the weak point of many models.
Okay.
I was testing its entire surface armor.
I was testing it!
I concluded that every side was strong.
Yeah.
Except the rear.
Yes.
Okay.
Good to know.
Thank you very much.
Except... Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot!
Ouchie!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Uh... Okay.
We have a...
...
Except the rear!
Oh!
That's the front, isn't it?
Oh my gosh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Not the splash damage.
Splash real!
I can't have him destroy the trucks though, right?
I can't...
I imagine that's how that should work.
Don't destroy...
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh!
Um, where are you now?
Snakes don't belong in Alaska.
Cool.
I got two.
Uh, where's the rear?
This is the rear?
Ouchie!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm bleeding out, I'm bleeding out, I'm bleeding out.
This should be a safe spot, maybe.
Hold on!
Oh my gosh.
Ouchie!
What are you talking about?
We're not even close to there!
A
lot of places, stuff to go to.
Two!
Aw, man.
I was so close to it.
I think it was just one more hit on the butt.
Okay.
Um...
That was also my fault because I didn't notice that it had finished reloading the cannon, so...
I arrived at the northern...
What the fuck?
Oh, uh, skip, skip, skip.
Okay.
And, let's attach.
Select, and...
And it's loading its cannon!
Maybe this is a safe spot.
Okay, maybe not.
Or, yes?
I don't know.
Here!
Load its cannon!
And grab this one, too.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Trying to get its butt!
Oh, here we go.
Oh, shoot.
I've learned that you can't hide behind the barrels.
Barrels are not a safe spot.
Please let me get your ass.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, gosh.
Guys, I think it's over.
Oh, that was so close.
Holy cow.
No...
Okay, I know, I know, I know.
Yippee!
Grrrr!
After dealing with the tank, I found the truck and hid inside.
Wait, but the other trophy!
The other medal!
I should have been selfish.
I should have been greedy.
And the military didn't find it weird that everything in the northern parking lot was destroyed?
Who knows?
Maybe it's a regular occurrence.
But the truck driver must have seen all that destruction.
Well, you know how military grunts are.
You only think when ordered to.
Complete the barracks.
Aw, I didn't get my troll.
I didn't get any secrets either.
Guys, I'm useless.
Chapter Six.
Engineering Problems.
So, in the end...
Oh, I forgot about this girl.
...you escaped hidden on that truck?
What about the shit you told me about not escaping in a truck to prevent pollution?
Because the first time it would have been me behind the wheel.
This time, the truck was going to leave with or without me.
Which means the pollution wasn't my fault.
Oh my god.
How convenient.
I kinda hate Jesse sometimes.
Oh my god!
Hey, it's the concrete paparazzi.
The concrete paparazzi.
Ha!
Such an asshole.
But I like it.
How's that escapee-ers going?
Making progress.
I'm currently stowed away in a truck.
Communications are hot.
You really pissed them off, Fox.
I guess we're both gifted with pissing people off.
Sorry about the concrete joke, by the way.
Nah, don't worry about it.
I don't get it.
What's the concrete joke mean?
Better have a sense of humor about being jailed over some concrete blocks.
By the way, you haven't seen it, right?
Yes, that's right.
But nothing as big as you mentioned.
Ah, well.
Send a postcard when you get home, my friend.
Okay.
Definitely.
Over and out.
Just some boxes.
I have no... I have no health.
Foxy, over.
What is it, Fox?
How were you captured?
We were heading to Kantor, a neutral zone.
When we were ambushed, no one else survived.
I doubt anyone back at base expects me to be alive either.
Hmm.
The truck stopped at last.
Its destination was a small port owned by the clandestine base.
Looked like the truck was carrying packages to be transported by sea.
As we arrived, I overheard a conversation between the driver and a hangar officer.
Huh.
I thought it said French.
Are you gonna tell me what the fuck you're bringing me at this time of night?
Sir.
I have an order to send this load by sea.
Fuck!
You're waking me up for this?
It's important, sir.
I already told your officer.
All maritime operations are cancelled.
We're waiting for the nuclear warheads to arrive.
And we won't ship anything else.
Until there's a new order.
Hold on.
You said nuclear warheads?
Yes, that's what I heard them say.
God save us.
That's impossible.
You sound just like the colonel.
Oh, report to colonel about the nuclear warheads.
Colonel Harris, are you there?
Here I am, son.
You sound tense.
Are you alright?
Why does it always go back to nukes, man?
I escaped in a truck.
I'm now in a hangar at a port.
That's great news.
Find a phone and call.
Not so fast, colonel.
It's an ex-army port.
I'm not safe yet.
Not safe?
I have new information about Operation Jericho.
Just overheard a conversation.
Sounds like they're waiting for nuclear warheads.
That's impossible.
Nuclear warheads?
Are you certain?
This can't be.
You just can't pluck nuclear weapons out of thin air.
They're extensively regulated.
Is it possible they stole them?
We don't have any news about any theft in any country.
If they were stolen, either a country hid the fact, or it happened while I was captain here.
Is it possible to build them?
These people have a lot of resources.
They need radioactive material and it can't be freely obtained.
We've been collecting radioactive material.
We've been collecting radioactive material like this entire time.
Whatever the case, they managed to acquire some.
We've been collecting it.
Hold on, Colonel.
I heard something.
Crap, they started the engine.
I'll call you later.
I have to jump out before the truck drives off.
It's scary.
Okay.
Close the door.
Oh my gosh, now we're trapped in here.
Get out of the hangar.
Let's collect a bunch of stuff first.
Yeah, yes.
Yes, give me more health.
Yes.
Oh,
that looks like a...
You guys, that looks like a nuclear warhead.
Maybe.
Nice.
I need that metal.
Can I use the binoculars in here?
Oh, wait, not combined.
There we go.
Oh, I can.
Look at them!
Look at the guys.
Wait.
Okay, I think if I go down...
Oh!
Hey, Leonard, look!
It's the prisoner!
How do you know who I am?
Leonard, not Mike.
These guys were Leonard's.
Mike doesn't fit engineers.
Quick!
Call for backup!
So they get the credit?
No way!
I'm fed up with them making fun of us.
Just because we're engineers.
Because we're Lennards.
They treat us like nobodies because we don't carry a rifle.
Our weapon is our intellect.
Do the controls!
We'll tell them we saw the prisoner.
No!
No, don't do that!
Wait, I can't skip this!
Oh, come on.
Guys, you're engineers.
Don't play soldiers with me, okay?
Come on, engineers.
Come on.
Let me pass.
I'll give you some trading cards.
Eat a dick!
Fine.
I don't know what you have on those computers.
But any unsaved work is going to get lost.
The saws were controlled by the terminals.
Okay.
I only had to destroy them.
There was a noise in the hangar.
A few explosions wouldn't draw any attention.
True.
But I had to be careful not to kill the engineers.
And heal them in case they got injured.
Oh, come on.
But they're just engineers.
I think I killed the engineer.
Uh-oh.
You guys, I think I killed the engineer.
I think he's down!
Uh-oh.
How am I supposed to get past this thing?
It's fine.
I would have game over it anyway.
Because of the guy.
Okay.
Gun.
Instead.
What?
It explodes anyway?
Oh my god.
Don't do this to me.
How am I supposed to get past?
Wait.
How am I supposed to get the third guy though?
Wait, hold on.
This seems like a puzzle.
Oh, I have this too.
I have this too.
But it explodes anyway.
So it doesn't matter.
The third console.
Roll?
It doesn't work.
I already tried that.
Um...
It does like so little damage too.
I don't want to waste all my uranium balls.
I can't hold on to it too.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
What can we do?
What do you think they...
What?
Bless you.
Thank you.
I like how they're just like gaming.
Bless you.
Thank you.
I can do this.
No, I can't.
Aw, dang it.
The one time.
Tasukawu.
Oh, grenade.
Oh, you guys are so...
Wait.
Okay.
We're going to have to be fast though.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
Um, um, um, um, um, um.
Oh my god.
No!
Okay, I'm going to have to roll through that one probably.
Stupid.
This is so dumb.
Oh, come on!
Oh, it's the saw in the end.
It's the saw in the end that gets me.
I tried rolling even.
I even tried rolling.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no, no.
Sorry.
Um, you first.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh, shit.
See, see, see.
He's fine, he's fine.
Oh!
Oh my god.
There's three more guys.
There's more saws.
There's this guy.
Okay, hold on.
So it's just similar.
It's similar to before.
Where we nade him.
And then...
Probably do him first.
Save spot?
Oh, like here?
You're right.
Okay, you first.
He's fine.
You're fine.
Everything is okay.
Oh, wait.
I think there was probably more health in there.
And I missed it.
No!
And that one right there, you see it?
Yes, sir.
Still trying to figure out how to get out of here.
By the way, guess what?
They have a mini rescue submarine.
Oh!
Rescue?
These people don't look like they go.
I'm getting inside to have a look.
Maybe I can ride it out of here.
Mm-hmm.
But if...
Oops, my bad.
If I go up...
If I go past the saw...
I can get it now.
There we go.
And get the grenade.
Just a little greedy.
We made it.
But what's here?
I inspected the mini submarine before I left.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sorry.
Trying to go out of the order of events.
What do we need for the submarine?
To leave.
What do we need?
Well, look at what we have here.
Files.
Fittling with the controls, levers, and compartments...
Mm-hmm.
I managed to discover the submarine's logbook.
It contained details about its last mission.
A rescue operation.
The details didn't catch my attention at first.
Until?
But this logbook turned out to hold exactly the answers we were looking for.
Jelly.
What's that?
What were we looking for?
The fourth document was the logbook of a mini rescue submarine.
It mentioned its last mission.
A successful rescue operation from a week ago.
What did they rescue?
The target was a sinking submarine.
A submarine to rescue another submarine.
The K278 Consomolets.
Suffering from an onboard fire in the Barents Sea.
The Barents Sea?
We'll see.
Nuclear torpedoes were salvaged during the job.
The warheads involved in Operation Jericho.
The third file of Operation Jericho was quite revealing.
It had a map of the Kantor Province with exact coordinates.
Coordinates.
An ambush plan.
And a picture of the Colonel with his name under it.
Apparently their plan was to kidnap the Colonel without leaving a trace.
And they did!
Fire underwater?
Water in the fire.
Why?
It also had a map.
So those numbers could be...
The coordinates of attack routes.
Or potentially the attack targets themselves.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, we've already seen the other ones.
We've seen this.
Okay, so we got more files.
Very cool.
Before leaving the submarine, I decided to report to Harris about the documents.
Okay, okay, okay.
Did you find anything, Fox?
Yes.
I reported at Mission.
It says, Mission Deep Rescue successfully completed.
Return date.
Fuck, a week ago.
I'll continue reading.
Rescue in the Barents Sea.
Submarine K270 Komsomolets.
We still don't even know who Jesse Fox is.
Like why he is here.
Have you heard of it?
Of course.
It's a Soviet submarine that sank after catching fire.
But I can't think of any connection between these scum.
He's just a guy.
Maybe they're a Russian faction and went to rescue their comrades.
Or they could be trying to trade the crewmen for Russian nukes or something.
Fox, this wasn't a rescue mission.
But the log says the Komsomolets sank over a year ago.
There's not a soul alive down there.
It's not people they were hauling.
It was something else.
Concrete.
Colonel, what was the sub armed with?
Ghosts.
A nuclear torpedo.
There it is.
The nuclear warheads for operation Jericho.
Kindly donated by the Soviet Union in a game of finders keepers.
If what you say is true, they had to bring those torpedoes in by sea and take them to a lab.
The whole Komsomolet had been contaminated by the radiation.
Which means they would need a sarcophagus.
A sarcophagus?
Like the one for Tutankhamun?
Did you smoke something, Colonel?
Don't be an idiot, Fox.
A sarcophagus is something that confines radiation, preventing everyone from dying while they transport the goods.
It has to be something thick.
Heavy.
Like concrete.
Two huge concrete blocks.
Yeah.
Robert!
What's up, Colonel?
I hear footsteps.
Soldiers are walking down the hall.
Damn it.
I think my time is up.
No, Colonel!
Listen to me carefully, son.
The situation is critical.
You have to escape as soon as possible and call the Cavalier.
Cavalier?
Is that not cavalry?
Colonel Harris out.
That was my final communication with Colonel Harris.
No!
My God!
Really?
Oh my gosh.
Colonel, do you copy?
You must have been taken.
Oh my God.
The Colonel is gone.
Robert, do you copy?
Fox looks like they're going to transfer a prisoner.
Someone called Alan Harris.
I know.
Do you know what they plan to do?
They're going to tickle him.
It looks like the orders are coming from top brass.
You're really pissing them off, my friend.
Be careful.
Maybe they'll use him against you.
We don't even know this guy.
By the way, I have something to tell you about your concrete.
Tell me him.
Man, you rock.
I don't know where they are.
But they've been used as a sarcophagus.
A sarcophagus?
Like the one for Tutton Common?
Did you smoke something, Fox?
I had a feeling he was going to say that.
I mean a thick container to contain radiation.
Radiation?
Please tell me they're not nukes.
They are.
From a sunken Soviet submarine.
Oh my God.
Shit.
That's why there's so much secrecy and surveillance.
Oh my God.
Cheer up, Robert.
Cheer up?
This isn't for something trivial anymore.
It's for a nuclear arms race.
Yippee!
This news is da bomb.
That's a literal way to say it.
Keep me informed, my friend.
I want to know all the deets.
Yeah, he wants to know all the deets so he can report it.
Over and out.
He wants to report it and be like, I'm the guy who figured all this out.
I think Robert's going to betray us.
I don't trust Robert.
Why did it save?
Why did the game just save?
Why are there so many missiles here, then?
Why is there a recycling bin?
Hmm.
Wait.
I guess we would leap through there.
But hold on.
Let's check this out first.
That's a recyc- Oh!
No!
Wait.
He's so environmentally conscious.
To get rid of some stuff.
But couldn't you just toss them on the ground?
Are you taking me for some sort of shitbag?
You were behind enemy lines.
It wouldn't be unreasonable.
He was like a protester or something.
I see.
Now, why did you get rid of items that may be handy later?
Because the more stuff you have, the more you're a slave to your own possessions.
And nothing enslaves me.
I threw away everything that I didn't need.
An act that's common to minimalists such as yourself.
Minimalist?
Me?
Where'd you get that stupid idea?
Take a look at yourself.
You look angry and disappointed.
As if you're having minimalist intercourse.
How dare you!
Relax, Sergeant.
It's obvious what Mr. Fox is trying to do.
We've been here for a long time.
We're tired.
Even slightly agitated.
I'm a slave to my possessions.
My anime girl possessions.
Hoping I attack him and provide an officer misconduct charge that enables him to be set free.
But that is not going to work, Mr. Fox.
Look, I'm used to interrogating assholes like you.
Fuck.
You got me, officer.
I underestimated you.
Fuck.
I have to admit that you're very good.
Pretty good, in fact.
Yeah, well, let's continue.
I'm getting flustered.
You said that you got rid of some items.
Yeah.
Wait, this is a lot of stuff.
No, my chloroform!
I guess...
Well, we still have the...
The wrapper.
Oh, we got a key.
Oh, wow.
They got rid of a lot of stuff.
I guess this is, what, halfway point of the game then?
Or am I a little further?
We don't need cigarettes in our stomach anymore.
I never even used a cigarette.
Wait, was there anything over here?
Oh.
Nope.
Weird area.
I know, it makes me...
Feel like there's a secret.
Is there a secret in there?
Can you punch the nukes?
Oh!
Wait,
where am I supposed to go from here?
What's this key?
Key.
Oh, okay.
Maybe to the front door.
I'm scared of punching the nukes, you guys.
I don't want to do that again twice.
Oh!
Okay.
This way?
Here?
Um.
The key didn't fit in the lock.
Well, where does it go then?
Does it go in the sub?
Marine?
To the sub?
Yeah.
I guess we're gonna try that.
Sub time?
Alright.
Okay.
After putting the key in the lock and turning it, the sub started to move.
I took the mini-submarine through underground channels beneath the hangar.
Seriously?
Now you can drive mini-submarines?
Nope.
Never done it before in my life.
But, I found a manual.
Wow.
Can you read Russian?
Oh, I was gonna think, can you read?
It was in English.
The mini-submarine was American.
It was a pretty smooth ride.
I didn't have to worry about the battery levels, oxygen...
Cinderella!
It was very comfortable.
I could practically live in there.
Well, of course.
It's an American product.
What did you expect?
Yeah, but you know how American vehicles are.
What are you trying to say?
They practically explode on contact.
Okay, that's true.
Ever seen an action movie?
Anyways, that's why I avoided any hard collisions.
Oh gosh, okay.
Up, down, left, right to move the submarine.
Oh gosh.
Oh, it has these kinds of physics.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Oh!
No!
What?
My HP was dropping.
Oh, is it because...
Oh, I see.
Oh my gosh, I can't hit anything.
Oh my god.
I see, I see.
You drop HP upon impact.
Oh, that's too difficult.
Okay.
Smooth ride my ass.
I don't think I'll fit through there.
Smooth.
Ride.
My butt.
I don't even know if this is the right way.
There was like that down way.
Maybe I should have gone the other way.
What was the other way though?
Can I go back in?
Wait, there's a bathroom.
It plays an old song called smooth.
Smooth operator.
Is this...
Okay.
It's a good thing we came here first then.
Oh my gosh.
No, no.
I have to go back through it?
Press space to shoot torpedoes.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Did they get shorter?
Is it just me?
No.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot the mines?
But what if they explode?
And I explode with them?
I don't want to shoot them if they're too close to them.
You know?
I don't want the splash damage.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
No way!
There's one of those things.
That's gonna like...
Okay.
Oh, this is gonna be...
This is gonna be torture.
How...
Maybe if I go up...
Was there a little pocket upwards?
Hmm.
You ate that torpedo for breakfast.
Yeah.
And then...
I had food poisoning.
Okay, but let me...
Okay, since we're here though...
Since we already died once...
Let's just try the torpedoes here.
See if it works.
You know?
Oh, my HP is back to full.
I got one at least.
Oh.
Hold on.
There we go.
Okay.
The angle is a little awkward, you know?
So...
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Good enough.
Here we go.
All right.
Yeah!
Okay.
Ha-ha-ha.
All right.
This part...
Oh, there is a pocket!
There is a pocket!
No!
I don't think I got anything though!
Ouch.
Oh, no!
My health!
You think I can go back and save?
You think I can go back and save maybe?
I wonder.
Oh!
Okay.
All right.
Oh, my God!
We'll blow these up.
I thought we would.
Okay.
And we'll grab more missiles too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Oh, come on!
That would have...
That should have...
That should have hit.
There we go.
Okay.
Perfect.
The Texas jokes.
Oh!
Hello again!
The parody is a full metal jacket.
They were so funny.
Ha-ha-ha.
I figured it out first try though.
Right, everybody?
Yes, me too.
Yes, sir.
I'm not a shit state.
Ha-ha-ha.
First try.
Nice.
All right.
Here we go.
Onwards.
Oop.
And I noticed something in the other room.
The one that had the...
Oh my gosh.
My health is not okay though.
Ha-ha-ha.
Maybe I should die and then load from the...
See that wall over there is kind of cracked.
Oh, ouch!
Oh!
I
thought it was a different room.
Ha-ha-ha.
I thought it was a different room.
Ha -ha-ha.
I thought it was a...
Ha-ha-ha.
Oh my gosh.
No!
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, see?
Our health is okay though.
Good, good, good.
Jesse doesn't die, it contradicts his story.
Ha-ha-ha.
So true.
My bad.
Yeah.
I'm getting pretty good at this though, I think.
I think I'm getting pretty good at the...
this whole driving thing.
Yeah, baby.
Ouch.
Oh, come on.
This thing is like the...
most delicate submarine in the world.
Most...
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
I took some hits.
I took some hits, but...
Um...
Wait, how am I supposed to get past these?
Oh wait, I think if I go like this...
Ah!
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
There we go.
Pogo ride?
Poco ride?
Oh, thanks for the raid!
It doesn't give me alerts anymore.
When someone raids me.
Thank you so much!
I'm doing the tiniest little bonks.
I'm playing a game.
It's a parody of Metal Gear.
Rareby, thanks for the 20!
Oh my god.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
But it's a very silly game.
Right now, we're trying to escape.
In a submarine, and it's...
A little tricky.
And requires...
Maneuvering...
Of impeccable timing...
And strength.
Oh, come on!
Okay, I'm gonna go...
After I destroy these, I'm gonna go save again.
That should be...
Yeah, okay, let's go save.
You can do it, company!
Thanks, Poco!
Thanks for the raid!
We should...
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, oh gosh.
Oh my gosh, I can't hit any walls, you guys.
Ow!
No!
All I say is I hit a wall.
Okay.
Can I use potty?
No.
I don't think so.
I don't think I can, at least.
I don't wanna... I'm like too glued...
To the...
Arrows?
The airbows?
The keyboard arrows?
That I don't wanna...
I don't wanna trust it at all.
I'm scared.
Oh gosh.
Okay, forward!
Yes!
That was so close.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, good.
Now if we explode...
Well, at least... And we can get more...
Oh wait, let me grab more...
Let me grab more torpedoes!
And...
Pee.
That's how you save in the game.
As you go and pee.
And yeah, I also destroyed this bathroom.
Don't even worry about it.
You can punch everything in this game.
Did you wash your hands?
We're in the water.
I don't need to wash my hands.
We're literally swimming around.
We're in nature's sink.
And nature's toilet.
All in one.
Reset health?
Oh, like immediately?
Uh, it's okay.
Let's see if I can do it.
I know it's probably stupid, but you know.
We might have... I might be a gamer.
Okay.
Oops.
That wasn't even intentional.
I don't... I don't even...
I don't care what you guys think.
That was not intentional.
I think I just was going a little too fast.
Okay.
I'll take it...
I'll take... around some of these corners I gotta go slow and steady.
No matter how good I think I am, physics decides that it has other plans for me.
Like here.
This one is tricky.
Oh my gosh!
I pressed the wrong button!
It's okay.
We only lost a little bit.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Never mind, I'm going this way instead!
Oh.
What is this?
Hugo?
Oh my god.
Ah!
You had to feel lonely.
Locked in that submarine.
Eh, it's in company.
I'm trying to get the medal.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I locked in too fast.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god.
Unagi blast!
Oh, okay.
He comes out of each hole.
Oh, it's a...
Don't bite me.
Yeah.
Get out of here, Hugo.
Boss defeated.
No!
Medical expert.
You can hold more than...
Four more maximum healing kits.
Gag reflex.
You sedate guards twice as fast and drag them faster.
Mentos.
Don't abide by laws of physics.
It's the rules of nature.
Boss defeated.
I think the gag reflex is alright.
But then I can hold more healing kits.
Gag reflex seems good for your playstyle.
I agree.
What's this down here?
More missiles?
I'm guessing.
Do I just go through the hole?
Easy now.
Easy.
Oh, the light!
At the end of the title!
I'm free!
Wow!
That stage wasn't very long at all.
There was a second secret.
I missed it.
What were the other holes?
Oh.
They might have been the secret.
For some reason I just assumed they were all the same.
The boom docks.
I ended up in what looked like a dock.
There were containers and stuff.
The sea was slightly rough.
Oh.
Oh, and there was a storm.
That's why the sea is...
Oh my gosh.
Just like yesterday.
I was in Akiba yesterday.
And it was like... it was...
Thunder.
Like, it was crazy storm.
Oh!
Okay.
I got a potty!
I got money!
Ten million dollars!
Wait!
I just got...
Huh?
Let's go!
Baby!
Under the rain and the biting cold, the colonel's fate gnawed at my mind.
According to Robert, they were moving him.
Was it a routine inspection?
Would he be returned to his cell?
Would they find the radio?
He was an old, annoying, tiresome man.
But I feared for his life.
Until the radio chimed in.
Channel One.
Colonel, what happened?
Are you okay?
I'm fine.
Mr. Fox, thank you for asking.
But my rank is general, not colonel.
Wait, you're...
General X?
So, Mr. Fox, have you heard?
You've become quite the celebrity.
I've been dying to meet you since your debut.
How'd you get my number?
So I took this hack job of a radio to call you before your inevitable capture.
Where's the colonel?
Don't worry about him.
He's in good hands.
Say hello, colonel.
Fox, run away!
Don't listen to this bastard!
Get your hands off me, you fucking moron!
Seniors say such silly things.
I join him in wishing you a happy escape.
But you know too much.
Sooner or later, you will make a mistake.
One that'll prove fatal.
We'll see about that.
General.
Roll.
Wow.
What about our friend, Line 2?
Jesse here.
Do you copy?
I hear you.
Nope.
He's still there.
Jesse here.
Over.
No one else wants to talk to me.
It's quite lonely.
Where is everybody?
I'm nervous.
Oh my god!
That's where everybody is!
Actually, you know what?
Let's just redo that.
Yeah, just kill me, actually.
If you don't mind.
Because I don't want to use my health.
Wait.
What can I draw with my blood?
There we go.
Some things require tight timing.
Okay.
We can skip this.
Oh, wait.
Let's also get our money.
And our potty.
A maid cafe.
Wait.
Only storks and dorks go to maid cafes.
Private storks?
You don't look much like a stork to me.
So that kind of narrows it down.
Oh my gosh.
Here they come.
This seems too easy.
Oh, excuse me.
Trying to use the water closet.
What if I am a stork, huh?
That's how I was done.
Delivered.
Nothing interesting.
Nothing, yeah.
More money!
What?
Wait.
Now we have 20 million dollars!
Nothing interesting.
Who are we?
Okay.
Nothing interesting.
I'm gonna have to dodge these.
Or roll through these, you know?
Are they gonna come from both sides?
Probably.
I'm scared.
Where are they?
More money!
This is getting ridiculous, you guys.
You assholes!
Oh, I guess I could've just bandaged that.
You know what?
I should've just bandaged it.
It's fine, though.
Nothing useful.
Oh, um...
Anyway.
What else is in here?
What else is here?
Useless stuff.
Nothing useful.
Okay.
Keep their asses quick.
That's what you gotta do.
That's what you gotta do, man.
I think I'll have to chloroform.
Well...
I think I just have to kick both of their butts.
What?
You guys were walking in tandem, and then what happened?
Purple box?
This one?
Did I not open this one?
I did, right?
Useless stuff.
Um...
We are on...
We got the chloroform, so...
Let's just have this on the ready.
Hmm...
Hmm... How do I want to do this?
No!
Don't walk away!
I don't...
I don't want to...
I don't want to alert them, because I want the...
XP.
Like that.
Hey!
Oh, a coin would be good for this, wouldn't it?
But I think we can still get him.
That's what the gag reflex did, baby.
It made him...
Oh my gosh, they go out so fast!
Useless stuff.
And I can drag them away so fast!
Hell yeah!
Money!
More money!
Hmm...
40 mil, baby!
I'm scared of walking along down here because of the guy.
Oh!
Oh, he's probably...
He probably wants me to give him money.
To get him...
To take me on the ship, right?
To get him... To take me on the ship, right?
She's a lovely ship!
Indeed!
And flies like the wind or the waves.
Is she yours?
She is!
I cut my finger.
Can you kiss it and make it feel better?
This beauty costs...
Fifty million dollars!
I doubt you can afford it.
Just fifty million.
I've got...
I'm a few dollars short.
Actually... Hold on.
I'm going to the ATM.
I don't have money.
So I searched in the containers.
Why in the containers?
I don't know.
It's how people usually smuggle money.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Buy the SS...
Velas.
For fifty million dollars.
What if the rest of...
What if the last... Well, we're already at forty million.
We just need ten more.
What if the last bit is in that one down there though, you know?
Hmm...
We're not smuggling money.
We're doing very legal activities.
Okay?
Nothing useful.
Nothing.
Yeah.
Oh!
That's useful.
Thank you.
Nothing interesting.
Wait!
But there's nothing else...
Blue crate at the beginning?
No, I got it.
Hmm...
Did you get the first box you used as cover against the boat?
The one near the save point.
The one over here?
I don't think I missed them at the beginning, did I not?
I thought I got all of them.
The blue crate after the beginning.
Nothing interesting.
I thought I got it though.
This one, you mean?
Oh my gosh.
I did get this one.
Nothing useful.
See?
So I got that one.
Next over.
Okay.
This one.
Boat money fund.
Oh, thank you.
I'm gonna... yeah.
I'm gonna start my GoFundMe.
Oh gosh!
You assholes!
I think I'm gonna have to just sit here and heal.
Well, I definitely did not get that one.
So thanks guys.
Oh, wait.
Actually, once I'm healed up...
This would be a good place to save.
Let's heal up.
Let's take a little breaky break.
Once we save...
Once we're all healed, we'll save.
And then...
We will buy ourselves a bow!
Because we've got 50 million dollars.
Easy peasy.
Make sure you wash your hands before you piss.
I broke the sink, sir.
What do I do now, sir?
The spot between the boxes.
What, this one?
Oh my gosh!
There's nothing in here.
Go to the other side.
Double secret.
Double secret, double secret.
Wait, how do I get to the other side?
Maybe I...
Is there a way to punch the wall?
That stairs is like over here.
Grenade the wall?
Like downstairs?
Grenades are not required.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
That so says the dev, everybody.
Grenades are not required in this part.
And I lied, but not this time.
A box to the right outside.
That's what I tried, though.
Unless it's like this one.
More stamina!
All right.
Yeah, it was further over than I thought it would be, too.
Very nice.
And we're all healed up.
Good job.
Good job, everybody.
Okay.
Let's go buy a boat.
And not get hit by another boat.
I shoot so fast, you guys.
I shoot so fast.
Oh, my gosh.
We made it.
Okay.
Perfect.
Hello, sir.
I have $50 million.
Yes, sir.
Thank you, sir.
Thanks, Mr. Krabs.
Yippee!
Yay!
Um.
And that's how I bought the ship I would finally escape in.
If only a lightning bolt didn't split her in two.
Beat him up!
Kick his ass!
Kick his ass, Jesse Fox!
About 50 million.
We got scammed, everybody.
I was gonna say it's probably here, but I just realized...
Oh no!
This guy.
Why can't I... There we go.
I didn't need it anyway.
There we go!
That scared the heck out of me.
Useless stuff.
Why are you guys so violent?
What if I was an actual employee?
What if I was on your team?
They knew exactly I was here.
That was so close.
Useless stuff.
Oh!
Bathroom.
Yes!
Occupational hazard.
You just gotta be ready for it if you work in these places, right?
It's just one of those things, you know?
Ashes!
It's late in my part of the states, but I wanted to say hi and I care you, Mintel.
Thanks!
I know it's pretty late for...
I got more money!
It's pretty late for when I usually stream, you know?
So I'm so sorry, you guys.
That it's been...
That I've been having to stream so much later than my usual times.
Nothing interesting.
I like how you guys say it's a red crate, but it looks purple to me.
Is that not purple?
Nothing useful.
Yippee!
I wonder if I can shoot them.
I wonder if I can shoot them down.
Nothing interesting.
OMG,
she rolled.
I've been rolling this whole stream!
What are you talking about?
What the?
What is this boss music?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Are you telling me that a nuclear submarine attacked you?
That's what I'm saying.
I see.
And now you're going to tell me you fought it instead of running away.
Wait!
Of course.
I would have left it alone if it didn't launch its missiles.
And nobody launches missiles at me without permission.
Jesse Fox versus the nuclear sub!
Um...
Oh, okay.
So I grenade it, I'm guessing.
That's why they're giving that to me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I can't touch.
Oh, no.
Oh, this is...
Not good.
Oh.
He's dead.
I'm done-zo.
Into the tubes?
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I was thinking too.
Okay, I don't think there was anything in these that like...
Oh, there was the money.
There was money in one of them, right?
We'll take the money.
There it is.
We'll take the cash money.
This one, it reminds me kind of of like the...
Remember how I...
There was...
Much earlier, we watched the first playthrough.
There was a...
Like a crate.
Thing.
And I just had to like...
Kind of go over slightly each time.
Sort of like that.
But just ruder.
Oh my gosh.
Beep, beep, beep!
Didn't I get an extra health somewhere too?
I thought I had six.
First aid kit in the purple container.
Okay.
And...
This one...
Over here?
Oh!
Come on.
Oh no.
I just wasted one.
Equivalent exchange.
All right.
Now this is...
Hmm.
Oh!
Ah!
I thought I had more time.
I'll be honest.
When it did the...
Pew!
I thought I was gonna do like the...
You know?
You know what I'm saying?
Like the...
Not the...
Pew!
But the...
You get what I'm saying?
They are quite fast.
Yeah.
They're pretty...
They're pretty speedy.
Yeah.
The key is to avoid the missiles.
Oh!
Okay.
That makes so much more sense than how I was doing it.
So...
Thank you for that tip.
Actually.
Fuck you!
There we go.
Okay.
Oh
my gosh!
Oh no!
Ow!
I don't even have enough time to punch a crate.
I forgot to save before I equipped the grenades.
My bad.
This one's tricky.
I don't even know if my grenades work when I threw it in there.
And there's four of them.
Throw!
Why isn't it throwing?
Why didn't it throw?
Wait.
How am I supposed to reach it now?
Oh my god.
Wait.
What?
Oh, they eventually burn out though.
Why isn't it throwing?
They do eventually burn out.
Oh man.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
The grenades do so little damage.
It's very low.
You need to throw a lot of them.
Okay.
Oh, whoops.
So I have to kind of like...
Oh my god.
I can't...
I can't walk anywhere on this damn place!
This sucks.
This... This sucks.
This sucks bad.
My timing sucks.
My health sucks.
This sucks.
I don't have any rockets.
I think I have...
Oh, I have a singular rocket.
So I could use...
My singular rocket.
I wonder though...
If it...
If I could be walking with it.
Can I just leave?
Okay.
I thought they would be...
So there we go.
Really
do just such a small amount of damage, huh?
Okay.
And I can't... You can't like spam.
That's the annoying thing.
The annoying thing is you can't really spam the grenades because you throw them so little at a time.
I can't get the stride down at all.
I'll let you go out in style.
Speedrun stride is simply a fun...
Yeah!
I think the tower does no damage.
I don't know.
I like how the rocket just went...
Right over the top.
I had a feeling that would happen but...
It just...
A single grenade can blow up to four to five crates in one blast.
Oh...
Now you're thinking with portals.
So if I like hit here...
Actually it doesn't change too much but it does...
Do good.
I
have no more grenades.
I think I'm in trouble actually.
Oh!
The rocket launcher...
Wait.
The rocket launcher can...
Can get the tower.
Oh my gosh.
Come on.
That wasn't even fair.
What the...
Oh my god.
Okay.
First things first.
We blow up all the crates.
We're taking care of those crates.
Oh!
Rocket launcher.
Come on!
Come on, man!
Why
do I get hit every time?
Why do I get hit every time?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
I can't move with the...
I can't move with the crates!
No, that's not what I meant to do.
My
finger placement and it messed me up.
Moving my fingers... I moved my fingers over and it...
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Okay, hold on.
I gotta get re-situated.
Okay,
so some of you guys said that going that vertically makes me slower.
What kind of sense does that make?
But I see it happening every time.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just gonna take...
Oh my god, fuck it.
I'm just gonna die.
Sigh...
Oh my
god.
I'm so scared.
I hate the...
You
guys, I don't think it's...
I don't think it's possible.
Invincible.
Oh, but my grenades!
What if I had gone on the other side?
I would have made it through.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for revealing your position.
Hey Fox, are you there?
Here I am, Robert.
Fox, the comms are fucking lit.
They're sending everything they have to the docks.
What the hell did you do?
I sank a nuclear submarine.
That'll teach it not to launch its missiles at me.
Are you kidding me?
I'm serious.
Good thing it wasn't armed with nuclear warheads.
They must be saving them for Operation Jericho.
Speaking of nukes, I'm hearing a lot of chatter that they're prepping their to the Omega building.
Man, if you don't stop them, there's gonna be a worldwide bloodbath.
I won't be stopping them.
But who else will?
I don't care, Robert.
Right now, I don't need to be recruited by another colonel to save the world.
Right now, I just need to save my ass.
And the moment I find anything, even a pool float, I'm getting the hell out of here.
A pool floaty.
I'm going back to my chloroform.
Oh, wait.
What's S mean?
These are like the quick controls, aren't they?
Actually, I haven't used it because I'm not sure how to.
Would you look at that?
There's a little metal over there.
It's probably safe.
Did it save?
It did.
Oh, gosh.
Get up.
Gasoline!
I don't know what I need that for.
Didn't we have that before?
Then we threw it out.
Didn't we have gasoline before?
I think we threw it out though.
Hold on.
I'm trying to fix something on my second monitor.
I was like, why can't I see on it?
It's because the brightness is all the way down.
Hello, sirs.
I'm going to throw a really cool penny at you guys.
Okay?
You're not even ever going to see it coming.
I at least got one of them.
Hey!
I'll take it.
Actually...
Oh, wait.
I think I already had it.
That's fine.
I did.
I'll take it.
Useless stuff.
Well, I'll take it.
Thanks, game, for being kind.
Anyway.
I'm going to heal up first.
It would have been hilarious if they both fought over the coin.
I didn't expect the one guy to notice me though.
Inside that hangar, I found what I was looking for.
Boats I needed to escape.
Yippee!
There was a zodiac motorboat.
And a hovercraft.
The zodiac was the faster and more maneuverable choice in the world.
I've ridden one of those in Antarctica.
But hovercrafts were versatile and could pass over terrain where zodiacs could not.
I rode a zodiac in Antarctica.
So I think I must go with the zodiac.
Out of experience.
It is my...
I'm an experienced driver.
Did I drive the zodiac myself?
Did we also almost get trapped in the ice in the zodiac?
Yeah.
Were...
Was I scared because the guy was just like, I don't think we should be in here.
And he still went in anyway?
Yeah.
You know.
So this one is...
As I checked the hovercraft, I found out that.
Oh.
Get what...
Get sleep...
Get well...
Get well soon...
Later.
Get well soon later.
Its gas tank was empty.
Oh!
Gasoline!
As I checked the zodiac, I found out that.
Its gas tank was empty.
Oh!
What did you...
What did you know that I had two things of gasoline?
What did you know?
What did you...
Wow.
Oh!
I guess we made our choice.
Left, right to move.
Space to shoot.
Machine gun?
Oh my god.
It's really fast.
How high?
Okay.
I'm just going to focus on the road, you guys.
Just going to focus.
Because this is one of the rare guns that I can actually...
Just shoot and not even...
Not even have to spam it.
I can just shoot.
Ah!
What about this one?
This one is slower though, right?
But I can go over more terrain.
I think this one is still better.
No.
Not combined.
There we go.
It
might work.
Nonsense!
Okay.
I'm going to try the other boat.
Just because I'm curious how well that one will work.
We fly off immediately, right?
Shoot the missile!
Oh...
This got some drift on it.
Oh no.
This sucks.
It's going to be way too slow.
Let's do heavy damage.
It's going to be way too slow, I think.
And it takes like a second to reload and everything.
See?
I can't even hit.
Get one-hitted.
See?
I can't even hit.
Get one-hitted.
I suck at this.
Aiming doko.
Oh my god.
It's because it's too slow.
Too slow.
You're too slow.
What is this?
I can't tell if it's a movie or a TV show.
And then I recognize this girl from Sabrina.
And then this guy...
I don't recognize him.
Sorry.
I have my TV on.
Hold on.
I'm just going to turn up the...
That's Tom Holland.
That's the Spider-Man.
Right?
Tom Holland is Spider-Man.
This guy looks like House, but I know he's not House.
It
looks like a spy movie.
Oh wait!
I missed the name.
It was in Nihongo.
Huh?
Can you hear it?
Who is that?
Uncharted?
Black Thunder.
That might be a reference to the movie Blue Thunder.
Are they...
You can hear it just a little bit.
It looks like a spy movie.
Okay.
Anyway.
Sorry.
My attention.
Okay.
Let's go.
There's only two hits and you're over.
I'm going to turn the volume down though.
It's a little loud.
Black Thunder!
There's so many missiles.
Oh!
I was not paying attention to the road.
It's like the number one rule.
I said pay attention to the road.
Maybe I should go back with this one.
This one is slower.
Slow and steady.
Right guys?
Black Thunder!
Oh!
Never mind.
Okay.
Let's go back to the Zodiac.
I wasn't steady at all.
It gets so narrow.
Get hit by one bomb at least.
Get hit by two bombs.
Yeah.
Number seven.
Oh my gosh.
I've already been streaming for four hours.
Um.
Hmm.
Thousand eyes are watching you.
The confrontation with that chopper exhausted every drop of gas I had left.
With no gas, the engine stopped shortly thereafter.
Despite the dangers, I used my own arms to paddle forward.
He can swim!
Piranhas and crocodiles constantly tried to eat my hands.
Why does he keep making this stuff up?
But I was lucky enough to make it to a small dock.
He's making it so much more difficult for me.
Oh.
Wait, but the boat is here.
That contradicts your story, Jesse Fox.
That's a great story.
You doubt him?
I'm just saying.
I'm trying to decide if I want to end it here now, you guys.
I've got some stuff I need to do before I go out today, so...
I've got some stuff I need to do before Oh, please don't kill me!
Why would I want to kill you?
Hold on.
He's like getting rid of the fence.
They took it!
That place.
It was isolated, with no roads or towns nearby.
And most importantly, he told me about what I might encounter up ahead.
Uh oh.
What might I encounter up ahead?
What... what might I... what might I encounter up ahead?
Security cameras!
A surveillance camera!
There, hidden in the middle of the jungle, stood a compound riddled with cameras.
The level of security was sky high.
Like the mansion of a cartel boss.
And I could see why.
Because the center of this fortress was the Omega Building.
The heart of Operation Jericho.
The old man told me that he saw some helicopters landing on top of the building.
If I stole one of them, that would be my ticket out of there.
One thing was for sure.
If I was detected by a camera, and the alarm triggered, they would put the Omega Building in lockdown.
And I could kiss those helicopters goodbye.
But none of that matters because, even though I was already showing signs of exhaustion, I slid in like a shadow and managed to go undetected.
I did?
Like a shadow?
Right underneath their noses.
Like that.
The door was locked and chained.
There was nobody outside.
So finding the key for the lock wasn't an option.
I could cut the chain with a bolt cutter, but...
Where would I find one?
We know.
I wish they showed us what the, um...
What the degree...
Give me that bolt cutter.
But...
It's mine.
We're just like them!
Now, it's mine.
We're just as...
They took his car?
They took his...
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you saying that you stole from some defenseless old man?
You're a special sort of monster.
What?
Me?
No, no, no, no, no.
Jesse...
I paid him.
When I said it was practically highway robbery, I meant...
Jesse...
Hello, friend.
Hello, Gramps.
I want to buy that bolt cutter.
But, it's mine.
How much are you willing to pay?
Here are some coins.
It's little money, pal.
I have ten million dollars.
I also have ten million dollars.
Okay.
Thank you, Gramps.
You're welcome, kid.
What if I didn't have the money?
What would have happened?
If I didn't have the money?
Okay.
There's like this old...
Old Love Hina, like, Newgrounds flash.
Maybe it wasn't Newgrounds.
I don't remember where I watched it.
But it was definitely... not safe for work.
It was Bpina.
And it was dubbed.
And the way that Keitaro just goes, Bokke.
Makes me laugh every time.
Bokke.
And like... like the... like Nauru was about to like start... I think like she...
Oh my god.
It's been so long since I watched it.
I used to... I probably watched it more times than I should admit.
Because the dub just made me laugh so much.
Bokke.
Poor memory.
True.
It wasn't Newgrounds though.
It wasn't Newgrounds.
The Newgrounds one... The Newgrounds Love Hina, I did play that.
That was the game.
But this was like an animated thing.
And the entire dub was just so bad.
Why do I say dub?
I don't know if it was like a dub, or if it was just the voice acting in general, or what.
On the east side, the cameras were accompanied by guards.
No!
Oh my god.
I needed to pass without being spotted by Mike or the camera.
What is that over there?
So, I had to get rid of Mike and leave no witnesses.
But it was more complicated than that.
If the camera saw Mike knocked out, lying on the ground...
It's real Metal Gear!
Seems you just had to move him away from the view of the camera.
Exactly.
But, if Mike wasn't there as the camera viewed his post, the alarm would still be triggered.
Whatever I did, the camera had to see Mike standing at his post.
What?
Hmm.
Quite the scenario.
Unless it's an episode of MacGyver, it would be impossible to proceed.
MacGyver.
Hold on.
If you're telling me this, that means you made it through, correct?
Well, yes.
I managed to fool the camera eventually.
How did you manage that?
If the camera needed to see Mike, I could just make a copy of him.
What?
A clone?
Oh no.
Yes.
The copy of him.
If the copy of him was so perfect, Mike's mother wouldn't know the difference.
I think it's closed.
I made the swap when the camera wasn't looking.
Wait, what do you mean when the camera wasn't looking?
What is this?
Oh, the camera moves.
Okay.
I know I said I was going to stop, and I did mean that.
I'm just trying to... I guess earlier would have been a good stopping point, huh?
We got a string.
Yeah, I can't see me.
Look, I even blend in with the wall.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I think that's it for me for today.
And...
We will finish, I think, what?
It's ten chapters, people said.
So I'm on chapter seven.
We only have three more chapters.
And I can't finish it up.
Next time.
Okay.
I'm so sleepy today.
But I have work to do.
And I gotta go do my work.
Thanks guys for joining me.
Sorry that I didn't finish.
I really had full intentions on doing it, but...
I am...
I got stuff to do.
This flashback narration thing is a brilliant way to get across game instruction to players.
Right!
It's awesome.
This game is so fun, actually.
Thanks for the stream.
I hope everyone has a good Labor Day weekend.
Although I don't think they have Labor Day in Japan.
What?
It's...
Is it Labor Day?
Oh!
It is Monday.
It is.
Well, it's Monday for me.
It's maybe probably Monday for some of you guys, too.
Um...
Yes.
I'm going to go there.
So...
If you're...
If you have a Labor Day off, get some rest as well.
And...
Yeah!
I don't feel so...
My tummy hurts only just a little bit, so...
I think I might be good for today.
Yeah...
Okay!
I'll probably finish it later this week.
I will put up a schedule.
I'm trying to figure out a little...
A little couple...
Hold on.
Um...
And I wrote...
Yes!
Oh!
Because I was supposed to do Love Ghosty yesterday, I'm actually doing it tomorrow instead.
Same time!
But, uh...
Yeah!
This is actually, like, my last week in Japan.
So, um...
From next week, I will have...
Things will be back to more normal.
So...
I can finally go home soon!
Yippee!
Yeah.
So, um...
I will see you guys later.
And, um...
Yeah!
See you guys later!
Bye-bye!
Thanks for watching!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!